so auf geht's muss gerade noch mal kurz auf dem zweiten rechner was gucken ich
muss ich muss domains verlängern noch fällt mir gerade auf also nicht wo bloß
wo bloß habe ich verlängert noch ein paar andere laufen aus habe ich gerade benachrichtigung
gekriegt anzeige ist raus warum laufen die aus ich habe die eigentlich auf autoverlängerung
aber meine billing information abgelaufen sind ja geil und ich habe gelesen leute es
gibt jetzt winter 3.0 ob das besser ist als 1.0 und 2.0
letztendlich sind zur point releases meistens gar nicht gar nichts wildes doch nicht irgendwo
habe ich das gelesen wenn jed 3.0 habe ich irgendwo habe ich das gelesen dass es jetzt
gibt ach bin get i use park wer braucht denn sowas aller wind yu-wei also wenn schon packit manager
kacke ist da kannst du es noch mal ein bisschen mehr kacke machen indem wir diese dafür vor wenn
es wo wir gerade dabei sind gut
Arch, by the way.
Oder Package-Updates machen.
WinGetUI ist der bessere App-Store, das glaube ich dir
sofort, ist aber auch nicht schwierig.
Nein, nein, nein, wir updaten garantiert nicht auf
17.5, 17.5 ist komplett
broken. Ich weiß nicht, warum 4M diesen Shit
überhaupt released hat.
Du meinst, welcher Web-Hoster kannst
du empfehlen, außer 1&1?
Äh, ich, keine Ahnung, ich hab
keinen Web-Hoster.
Ich, äh, weiß, weiß ich...
Meinst du Web-Hoster
wirklich, oder meinst du Domain-Registrar?
Domain-Registrar
hab ich bestimmt 5 verschiedene.
Ich hab, äh, Name-Cheap
was, bei Pork-Bun hab ich
was, bei, äh,
wie heißen die
nochmal? Nitrado hab ich tatsächlich
auch noch was, bei Cloudflare
hab ich was.
Ich glaub, das war's.
Bilde mir ein, aber es sind 5.
Ah, nee, Name-Silo.
Name-Silo, ja.
Aber die hab ich da auslaufen lassen,
alle, das war nur zu Testzwecken.
Warum ist denn das Update so langsam?
Was ist da los?
Oh.
Wait a minute, warum hab ich...
Okay, ich glaub, es ist einfach
nur großes Update. Ich hab
140 MB, das kann doch eigentlich
gar nicht sein. Warum hab ich denn so viel
Receive? Macht mein Browser irgendwelche komische
Dinger?
So viel kann ich gar nicht empfangen, ich hab nur 400 MB
down, Internet-Stells.
Wie soll ich da angeblich,
136 MB machen?
Das ist mehr als ein Gigabit.
Also bei Hexner kannst du in der Regel nichts
falsch machen. Außerdem haben die ein gutes
Web-UI. Ich weiß aber nicht, wie gut das
Web-UI ist für reines
Web-Hosting. Ich benutze
da eigentlich immer nur die VMs.
Proxmox ist hart am
Kommen gegen VMware.
Ja, verstehe ich auch.
Ganz ehrlich, gerade seit der
Prodcom-Übernahme blickt da echt keine Sau mehr durch.
Aber ich geh davon aus, dass
im Business-Enterprise-Umfeld,
wo auch mit Support-Verträgen und
alles um sich geschmissen wird und
siebenstelligen Budgets,
das weiterhin VMware bleiben
wird,
das ist so ein bisschen selbsterhaltendes
Ökosystem, VMware.
Oftmals sind das so
große Technik-Sachen. So,
Shitrix ist auch so ein Ding.
Hat jemand, Leute,
benutzt jemand Netscaler? Kennt jemand Netscaler?
Das ist auch so ein
selbsterhaltendes Ökosystem aus
Produkten und
Experten,
die sich, ich glaube, da kann man sich sogar
zertifizieren lassen und sowas.
Auch ganz grausames Ding, ey.
Windows-Server ist auch selbst,
naja,
ja, ein bisschen halt die ganze
Microsoft-Welt mit Zertifizierung.
Aber jetzt nicht so krass wie beispielsweise,
dass jetzt bei VMware der Fall ist.
Oder bei Citrix
oder sowas.
Hättest du ja deinen Account gelöscht
wegen sechs Monaten Inaktivität. Echt jetzt?
Warum macht man sowas?
Könntest du einfach wieder was kaufen?
Also ich hab auch schon lange nix mehr in der Cloud laufen lassen.
Ich glaube, die höchste Cloud-Abrechnung der letzten Monate waren mal 34 Cent oder so.
Also hält sich in Grenzen.
Soll ich mal kurz andere Musik anmachen?
Das ist eigentlich nur als Intro gedacht, aber jetzt haben wir schon zehn Minuten.
Was haben wir denn hier? Chill.
Oh ne, das ist mir zu chill.
Ich brauch jetzt mal ein...
Oh, ich weiß.
Ah, yes.
Alter, was macht das denn da im Hintergrund?
Compressing Image auf drei CPU-Cores.
Okay, nur noch auf zwei CPU-Cores.
Ach, Visual Studio Code wird compressed.
Was wird denn das für so lange? Compressed?
Aha.
Ultra-Compress.
Also ich hab keine Ahnung, ob die günstiger sind.
Aber ich habe von...
Nerds Cave Hosting noch nie was gehört.
Hetzner ist meistens eine super Kombination, weil es günstig ist und recht zuverlässig.
Kennt das jemand? Nerds Cave Hosting hab ich noch nie gehört.
Das flexibelste Web-Hosting.
Okay.
Okay, die machen anscheinend wirklich nur...
Ne, wobei, du kannst ja da auch VMs kaufen.
Hab ich nur...
Wow!
Das ist aber ganz schön teuer.
Das ist ganz schön teuer.
Für eine VM.
Zwei-Core-VM.
Zwo Gigabyte.
Das ist ja...
Das ist echt teuer.
Da stand flexibel, nicht flexibel.
Was auch immer das jetzt heißen soll.
Wo steht da was von flexibel?
Ich seh da nix.
Ja, ich kenn das auch nicht.
Ich seh jetzt auch den Sinn ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Ja, Google Cloud sind eure Partner natürlich, ist klar.
Auf der Index.
Auf der Index-Seite.
Ja, da steht, dass die flexibel sind.
Das ändert aber ja an den VPS-Preisen nix.
Also, warum das? Hab ich keine Ahnung.
Ich mein...
Hetzner Cloud, also meine Lieblingskiste.
Sind das vielleicht echte CPU und keine V-CPU?
Also...
Es ist ne VM.
Oder meinst du quasi, du kriegst dann auf einer...
Das kann nur auf einer Hardware laufen.
Kann sein, aber es macht letztendlich überhaupt keinen großen Unterschied.
Also bei Hetzner kriegst du...
Also meine Lieblings...
Machen wir mal IPv6 oder...
Naja, je nachdem.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen unfair.
Je nachdem.
Machen wir mal Primary IPv4.
Also meine Lieblings...
Lieblingssache ist...
Guck mal, Hetzner ist deutlich, deutlich, deutlich günstiger.
Sogar Dedicated-VCPU.
Aber meine Lieblingssache bei Hetzner ist entweder...
Wenn's x86 sein soll, die hier.
Drei V-CPUs, 4 GB RAM, 80 GB NVR.
Das ist ein...
Das ist, finde ich...
Ja.
Richtig nice Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis.
Man kann sogar die IPv4-Adresse weglassen, wenn man da mehrere Kisten hat.
Irgendeine Gateway.
Das finde ich...
Also für mich ist das die beste Kombination.
Also du kriegst drei CPUs, 4 GB RAM, 80 GB SSD.
Das ist...
Das ist echt super Kombination.
Ja, man kann sich auch sowas hier überlegen, weil man eben doppelt so viel RAM braucht.
Aber die hier.
Das ist meine Lieblings-VM.
Damit mach ich nahezu alles, wenn ich...
Wenn ich mal irgendwas mache.
In letzter Zeit.
In letzter Zeit ist ja nicht viel.
Also...
Ich finde, dass es...
Also wenn's x86 sein soll, die preis-leistungsmäßig die beste VM.
Natürlich, wenn ihr nicht das braucht.
Ja.
Ich mein...
Holt euch auch die kleinen.
Das macht nichts.
Aber insgesamt preis-leistungsmäßig finde ich die...
Finde ich die super.
Ja.
Neun Euro für das.
Oder wenn ihr nicht x86 braucht.
Die Dinger sind auch nicht schlecht.
Da gibt's potenziell mehr RAM für den gleichen Preis.
Und mehr CPUs.
Wobei...
Ne?
Du kannst ja...
ARM64 und x86 Leistungsfähigkeit nicht so direkt miteinander vergleichen.
Also...
Wahrscheinlich ist das hier ungefähr...
Wenn man einen guten Multithreaded Workload hat.
Ähnlich schnell wie das hier.
Also wie die 3er dort.
Dafür kriegst du 4 GB mehr RAM.
Ja.
Also ich hatte mir letztens mal eine...
ARM-VM gekauft.
Um darauf was zu machen.
Und...
Ich weiß nicht mehr was.
Ich hatte zumindest Probleme damit, weil es ARM-Architektur war.
Und das was ich ausprobieren wollte irgendwie nicht richtig für ARM funktioniert hat.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern was das war.
Aber zu 95% sollte das hier eigentlich gar kein Problem sein.
Ja.
Wenn man sowas dauerhaft haben will.
Und sich das vielleicht auch ein paar Monate gönnen möchte.
Weil man da was größeres drauf macht.
Oder noch länger.
Ist die Server...
Ist diese Server-Auktion...
Auch gar nicht schlecht.
Da kriegst du so olle Dinger.
Für relativ wenig.
Insgesamt muss man sagen.
Was Dedicated-Servers angeht finde ich Hetzner auch nicht schlecht.
Weil...
Ich habe gerade letztens geguckt.
Wir machen ja auf der Arbeit relativ viel Blockchain Gedöns.
Und ich habe mal da geguckt was...
Man hier für...
AMD Systeme bekommt.
Mit NVMe SSDs.
Mit viel NVMe Storage.
Und das ist echt nicht schlecht gewesen.
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht mal was ich...
Ich weiß nicht mal was ich dort hatte.
Ich hatte eine Kiste mit 8 NVMe SSDs.
Na so viele gehen hier beispielsweise gar nicht dran.
Mit 8 NVMe SSDs.
Und das war preislich echt nicht schlecht.
Kann man hier nicht noch mehr dran machen?
Nicht noch mehr Disks?
Ach doch hier.
Genau.
Ah ne.
Aber hier kriegt man nicht mehr dran.
Hier könnte man noch mehr machen.
Ich habe mir eine konfiguriert mit glaube ich...
Lass mich jetzt kein Mist erzählen.
Ich glaube 18 TB NVMe.
Und das hat auch irgendwie glaube ich nur 380 Euro oder so gekostet.
Also wenn man sowas braucht ist das richtig nice.
Hetzner sagt aber offiziell dass man keine Blockchain Sachen bei ihnen laufen lassen kann.
Trotzdem sind witzigerweise ein Großteil der Infrastruktur von manchen Blockchains trotzdem auf Hetzner.
Also...
Ja.
Was auch immer ne.
Okay ist fertig.
Ich mache Blockchain genug jetzt.
Ich arbeite bei einer Versicherung.
Und wenn die Frankfurter Finanzbranche irgendwelche Trends mitgekriegt hat.
Dann kannst du davon ausgehen dass die eigentlich schon 1-2 Jahre outdated sind.
Also die einzige Public Blockchain die erwähnenswert ist aktuell bei uns ist Polygon.
Wir haben noch ein paar Private Blockchains angebunden.
Wo man dann mit irgendwelchen Partnern Dinge macht.
Wo ich jetzt nicht weiß.
Wie im Detail ich das erzählen kann.
Aber Polygon ist glaube ich das bekannteste von dem was wir haben.
Wo wir eigene Nodes für haben.
Und ich sage euch Leute so ein Polygon Node betreiben ist abfuck hoch 10er.
Nächstes Jahr NFTs.
Kann durchaus sein.
So Trends brauchen immer 2-3 Jahre bis die so bei Banken und Versicherungen.
Und bei größeren Dienstleistern in der Finanzbranche in Frankfurt ankommen.
Die ein bisschen langsamer sind.
Bisschen Daten nein.
Hat nichts mit Datenaustausch zu tun.
Du kannst darüber beispielsweise Wertpapiere handeln.
Oder ich muss jetzt überlegen was ich erzähle.
Assets kannst du handeln.
Das ist doch das 0815 Wort schlechthin.
Assets.
Assets ist immer gut.
Das ist so nichtssagend.
Ehrlich gesagt ich bin mir selbst nicht so ganz sicher warum die das so geil finden.
Ich gehe mal davon aus weil du dort neue Produkte rausbringen kannst die es vorher noch nicht gab.
Und im Zweifelsfall aber das jetzt von mir geraten.
Ich habe keine Ahnung ob das stimmt.
Vielleicht kann man damit auch irgendwie Steuern sparen.
Kein Schimmer.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Warum die da so scharf drauf sind.
Also es kostet auf jeden Fall weniger Geld.
Das habe ich schon mal raus gehört.
Wenn du auf klassische Wege handelst.
Dann hast du halt ein paar Leute dazwischen.
Und wenn du es über Blockchain Geschichten handelst.
Dann ist das günstiger.
Sachen zu handeln.
Und wahrscheinlich kann man auch ganz neue Produkte entwerfen.
Wenn man sowas hat.
Also von der Business Seite aus habe ich ehrlich gesagt wenig Ahnung was da eigentlich genau mit passiert.
Aber ich kann euch sagen.
Ein Polygon oder nicht nur ein.
Polygon Nodes selbst zu betreiben ist super abfuck.
Also die haben zwei Sachen.
Die haben einmal so einen Test Polygon Netzwerk.
Und einmal das produktive Polygon Netzwerk.
Und bei dem einen forken und ändern die laufend was.
Sodass du permanent irgendwie an deinen Nodes rumschrauben musst.
Dass sie weiter funktionieren.
Und Polygon Nodes selbst betreiben.
Gerade wenn es ein kompletter Node ist.
Ist halt extrem speicherintensiv.
Und wir reden hier von Terabyte die du brauchst.
Also aktuell.
Um die 12 Terabyte.
10 Terabyte glaube ich.
Ist vielleicht sogar ein bisschen mehr mittlerweile.
Ist die Polygon Blockchain komplett.
Zur Zeit.
Und wird halt im Prinzip auch immer noch mehr.
Wobei man glücklicherweise meistens nicht so einen ganzen Archiv Server braucht.
Für das was man machen will.
Also es ist sehr Storage intensiv.
Und.
Was echt krass ist.
Es ist sehr Storage Latency intensiv.
Das hätte ich auch nicht gedacht.
Also rein auf IOPS zu gucken.
Also wir verwenden beispielsweise.
Also nicht nur aber auch.
Wir verwenden das hier für Polygon.
Das ist ein Open Source Client.
Der kann nicht nur Polygon.
Der kann alles mögliche.
Und.
Das Ding ist.
Das Ding braucht.
Storage Latency.
Storage Bandbreite.
Und Storage IOPS.
Und Chat.
Mal an die Hyperscaler.
Fans unter euch.
Man ist heutzutage jetzt immer so nebenbei erwähnt.
Heute sagt man nicht mal Cloud Anbieter.
Wenn man besonders cool sein will sagt man Hyperscaler.
Und wir wollen ja hier natürlich besonders cool sein.
Deswegen.
An die Hyperscaler Enjoyer unter euch.
Was meint ihr was am schwierigsten zu bekommen ist im Cloud.
Sorry im Hyperscaler Umfeld.
Im Cloud Umfeld.
Was meint ihr was am schwierigsten zu bekommen ist.
Storage.
Mit ordentlich Bandbreite.
Also MB pro Sekunde.
Storage mit.
IOPS.
Also was gut ist für irgendwelche.
Random Read Rights.
Oder.
Storage Latency.
Es hängt natürlich alles ein bisschen zusammen.
Aber sind schon drei unterschiedliche Größe.
Storage mit Bandbreite.
Alles drei.
IOPS hätte ich jetzt gesagt.
Also ich kann euch sagen.
Der Alfred hat Recht.
Das mit Abstand Schwierigste ist Storage Latency.
Zu kriegen.
Es gibt im Prinzip keinen Cloud Anbieter.
Keinen der großen Cloud Anbieter.
Die ordentliche Storage Latency.
Haben.
Egal ob es Google ist.
AWS weiß ich nicht.
Aber AWS glaube ich auch nicht.
Aber weder Google noch Microsoft.
Hat ordentliche Storage Latency.
Das liegt daran.
Weil die SSDs.
Die man sich beispielsweise bei Google und Azure.
In seine VMs hauen kann.
Gar keine echten SSDs sind.
Das ist nicht so.
Dass du etwa eine SSD durch gepasst.
Throot bekommst oder so.
Ne ne.
Das sind alles irgendwelche Storage Systeme.
Die übers Netzwerk dann bereitgestellt werden.
Und auf eurem Betriebssystem so aussehen.
Als wäre es eine SSD.
Irgendeine SSD.
Aber es ist nicht wirklich.
Eine direkt angeschlossene SSD.
Auch wenn es so aussieht.
Unter Linux.
Was ihr da kriegt.
Das geht immer übers Netzwerk.
Und die Latency ist grausam schlecht.
Die ist wirklich im Millisekunden Bereich.
Die hat teilweise 7-8 Millisekunden.
Storage Latency.
Das ist nix.
Also nur mal zum Vergleich.
Hier in meiner VM.
172 Microseconds.
Und das ist meine VM hier.
Da landet wahrscheinlich auch einiges.
In Cache und so.
172 Microseconds.
Habe ich hier Storage Latency.
Und in der Cloud ist das hier im.
7-8 Millisekunden Bereich.
Das ist extremer Unterschied.
Das ist wirklich krass.
Und diese Blockchain Geschichte.
Zumindest Polygon in dem Fall.
Mit diesem Client den ich euch gezeigt habe.
Der ist.
Mega anfällig.
Für Storage Latency.
Und ihr findet keinen Cloud Anbieter.
Der das kann.
Deswegen ist beispielsweise auch.
Ich kann euch mal was vom alten Arbeitgeber erzählen.
Was das auch nochmal unterstreicht.
Beim alten Arbeitgeber wo ich war.
Hatten wir ganz viele.
Also wir haben unser E-Mail System damals noch selber gemacht.
Und E-Mails.
Könnt ihr euch ja vorstellen.
Bestehen aus ganz ganz vielen kleinen.
Oftmals nur ein paar Byte großen.
Dateien.
E-Mails halt.
Da hast du E-Mails.
Die sind nur.
Da kommen die Header noch dabei.
Ein Kilobyte.
Vielleicht sogar ein bisschen weniger.
Wenige Kilobyte.
Ganz ganz viele Mini Dateien.
Kleiner 4K auch.
Also wirklich ganz viele mit kleinen Dateien.
Milliarden kleiner Dateien.
Und bei Azure.
War die einzige Möglichkeit.
Das.
So anzubinden.
Weil es dich halbwegs lohnt.
Über Azure Files mit NFS.
Und das konntest du komplett vergessen.
Die NFS Latency ist so krass gewesen.
Bei Azure.
Unter anderem halt auch.
Einmal weil es NFS ist und eh schon übers Netzwerk geht.
Aber auch um das Storage unten drunter.
Das war pro Stat auf einer Datei.
Millisekunden.
Anstatt Mikrosekunden.
Und das war so.
Abartig.
Unbenutzbar langsam.
Dass du damit nichts anfangen konntest.
Storage Latency ist im Cloud Umfeld echt nicht einfach.
Was du machen kannst ist.
Deswegen war auch der Grund.
Warum ich damals bei Hetzner geguckt hab.
Was es hier für fette Kisten gibt.
Und da kriegst du für 400 Euro 450 Euro im Monat.
Richtig fette Kisten mit lokalen NVMe SSDs.
Ich hab das mehrfach auf der Arbeit vorgeschlagen.
Hab ich gesagt ey wisst ihr was.
Scheiß egal.
Alle Blockchain Nodes haben doch eh das gleiche.
Wir können auch einfach unsere Node bei Hetzner hosten.
Wollten sie aber nicht.
Wahrscheinlich ist sie in Hetzner nicht Business Enterprise genug gewesen.
Bei Hetzner bezahlst du halt 450 Euro für eine fette Kiste.
Die genau das macht was du brauchst.
Bei Google bezahlst du halt 8000 Euro im Monat.
Aber whatever.
Wenn sie halt wollen.
Dann wollen sie.
Zumindest die einzige Möglichkeit bei Google.
Um niedrige Storage Latency zu bekommen.
Sind Local SSD.
Nennt sich das ganze.
Das Problem ist.
Bei Local SSDs.
Die sind nicht groß genug.
Die sind nur 9TB bei erschwinglichen VMs.
Und maximal 12TB bei super teuren VMs.
Und diese SSDs.
Werden auch nicht etwa in einem großen Block bereitgestellt.
Sondern.
In 375GB Blöcken.
Also du bekommst dann.
Wenn du.
Hier.
Ach guck mal.
Hä?
12?
Ach guck mal.
Jetzt.
Wir haben da so lange rumgemeckert bei Google.
Hier guck mal.
Nur mit Maschinen Z3 Vorschau.
Ok die werden wahrscheinlich dann.
Super krass teuer sein.
Also erschwinglich waren eigentlich nur die hier.
Mit erschwinglich meine ich.
Du hast dann für eine VM.
Mit ordentlicher Ausstattung und lokalen SSDs.
Ungefähr 2500 Euro im Monat bezahlt.
Bei Google.
Und ihr seht.
9TB sind zu wenig.
Und außerdem ist der Inhalt.
Wenn du deine VM ausschaltest.
Und wieder einschaltest weg.
Das ist mega beschissen.
Also du kriegst einfach keine gescheite Storage Latency hin.
Google.
Außer mit Local SSDs.
Und die sind in der Handhabung kacke.
Also das hier ist hyper teuer.
Geh ich mal von aus.
Ja so sieht es aus.
Und bei Azure ist es im Prinzip das gleiche.
Ja und du kriegst das bei Google auch nur.
Bereitgestellt in 375GB Häppchen.
Das heißt du musst dir da noch ein eigenes.
RAID 0 drüber bauen.
Kannst vergessen.
Das taugt in der Cloud nichts.
Hast du eigentlich eine Handyhalterung und Fahrradtasche am Bike?
Oder fährst du mit Rucksack?
Ich habe eine ganz kleine Fahrradtasche.
So ein Ding von Amazon.
Was man unter sein Rohr montiert.
Und als Handyhalterung habe ich.
Habe ich auch.
Ich habe ein.
Wie heißt das?
Log Stem Mount.
Ich glaube ich habe sogar noch eins.
Hier das da.
Das Teil habe ich als Handyhalterung.
Extra iPhone Hülle für.
Die ist aber richtig nice die iPhone Hülle.
Die habe ich mittlerweile auch standardmäßig drum.
Die fühlt sich sehr stabil an.
Die benutze ich normal auch.
Du musst quasi die.
Die Original Kappe.
Von deinem wie nennt man das so Lenkerhalterungs Ding.
Musst du raus schrauben.
Und die Kappe dafür drauf machen.
Dann kannst du dein Handy da vorne drauf klatschen.
Die Hülle.
Die kriegst du auch bei Amazon hier.
Kannst du hier gleich mit dabei bestellen.
Guck da.
Kannst du sogar das Set kaufen wenn du willst.
Hülle Plus Halterung.
Was das für komische Klingeln sind weiß ich nicht.
Ich gehe davon aus das es einzeln günstiger ist.
Ja.
So sieht es aus.
Das kommt drauf an wie teuer dein Rechenzentrum.
Und alles drum herum ist.
Das würde ich gar nicht mal so sagen.
Ja.
Ich bin da schon sehr hoppelige Wege gefahren.
Da passiert nichts.
So habe ich jetzt eigentlich alles geupdatet.
Und rebooted.
Ja ne.
Aber rebooted habe ich glaube ich nicht.
Arch by the way.
Keine Ahnung habe ich nicht ausprobiert.
Wahrscheinlich wackelt es zu sehr.
Ok genug.
21 Minuten.
Boah er ist am Start.
Eigentlich hatte ich jetzt gar nicht vor.
Die ganze Zeit Arch Updates zu machen.
Aber was sein muss, muss sein.
Hast du einen Nas?
Jetzt.
Was ist da drin?
Was ist in den Sachen bezogen?
Ne.
Dafür nicht.
Daheim ja.
Daheim schon.
Aber kein Nas im klassischen Sinne.
Ich habe so einen HP Microserver seit ein paar Jahren.
Und da liegt auch ein bisschen Netzwerkstorage drauf.
Also kein Gerät was man sich so fertig als Nas kauft.
Gibt es davon eigentlich.
Was neues mittlerweile?
Gen 10 plus V2 gibt es jetzt.
Ok.
Was ist da jetzt drinne?
Eine schlechte Bewertung das Ding.
Warum?
Was ist da jetzt?
Alter warum sind diese ganzen Business Enterprise Seiten so...
Shit.
Kann mir das mal jemand erklären?
Die IBM Seite ist auch beschissen.
Die HP Seite ist beschissen.
Ich gucke jetzt bestimmt nicht bei Bechtle.
Weil ich...
Ok guck mal bei Geiz halt.
Ist vielleicht sinniger.
Ok was so super spannendes ist jetzt ja da auch nicht drinne.
Ok was so super spannendes ist jetzt da auch nicht drinne.
Die sollen das mal rausbringen mit aktuellen Ryzen CPUs oder sowas.
Das stimmt die Seite funktioniert immerhin.
In welcher...
Ah jetzt gehts.
Ach das ist ein PDF.
Seriously.
Man macht dann ein PDF auf dafür oder was.
Die sind lost bei HP.
Die sind lost.
Ich sehe hier ein Intel Pentium Gold.
Also da lohnt sich definitiv kein Upgrade.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher was ich eigentlich habe.
Ich muss mal kurz bei Amazon gucken.
Ich glaube ich habe den damals bei Amazon gekauft.
Mal schauen.
Kennst du Hoster wo man viel Speicher bekommt für kleines Geld?
Ne.
Also ich fand die...
Hetzner Ryzen Kisten ziemlich gut.
Wenn man viel SSD Storage braucht.
Aber das ist garantiert nicht kleines Geld mehr.
Da sind wir schon bei 350-450 Euro im Monat.
Micro...
Du brauchst als SSD so 18 TB oder sowas.
Ne habe ich nicht bei...
Ah shit.
Ne habe ich anscheinend doch nicht bei Amazon gekauft.
Ich hätte mir ein Bild betten können.
Das habe ich mir bei Amazon gekauft.
Alter die haben sich verschrieben.
Ich fasse es nicht.
Ich habe nach Microserver gesucht.
Da sieht man mal wie kacke.
Im Monat ja.
Aber das ist immer noch günstig.
Bei Google bezahlst du fürs gleiche 2500 Euro im Monat.
Bis 3000 Euro.
Ich habe nach HP Microserver gesucht.
In meinem Amazon Account.
Nichts gefunden.
Und warum?
Weil das Ding Micro SRV heißt.
Da hat sich irgend einer verschrieben.
Oder wollte besonders cool sein.
Hat es abgekürzt.
Die Suche bei Amazon ist auch schon richtig kacke oder.
Jede Suchmaschine schafft es.
Microserver zu finden.
Wenn ich nach Micro SRV suche.
Guck hier.
Überhaupt kein Problem.
Oh.
Wie der Postleitzahl liegt.
MonkaS.
Die fünfte Postleitzahl oder so.
Rebootet. Alles gut.
Heute müssen wir weiter machen.
Unser Zigbee Gerät.
Unser eigenes Zigbee Gerät bauen.
Dann müssen wir jetzt mal langsam den Temperature Sensor anschließen.
Und gucken wie wir das ordentlich per Zigbee verschicken.
Ja aber.
Wenn ich in meiner Bestellhistorie suche.
Noch nicht mal das.
Da findet er einfach nichts.
Storage Box.
Je nachdem was du halt an Storage brauchst.
Wenn du wie gesagt.
Wenn du Storage Latency brauchst.
Dann ist wahrscheinlich die Storage Box auch nicht das sinnvollste.
Die geht nämlich garantiert auch über das Netzwerk.
Auch wenn es auf deinem.
Auf deiner VM so aussieht.
Als wäre es.
Eine direkt angeschlossene SSD.
Wette ich mit euch.
Dass es auch über das Netzwerk geht.
Einfach eine preisliche Frage.
Ja das stimmt.
Wobei er hat ja auch nicht gesagt.
Ob er niedrige Latenzen braucht.
So.
Dann lasst uns doch mal schauen.
Was bei Shithub.
Wobei das kommt.
Das gucken wir heute mal unter Linux.
Was auf Shithub so trendet.
Github Trends.
Mein Netzwerk ist disconnected.
Ja deswegen kann ich auch Github aufmachen.
Also was haben wir.
Blazingly Fast.
Written in Rust.
Aber 506 Sterne.
Aha.
Okay.
Was ist Ore?
Hat das was mit Crypto Mining zu tun?
Kann man danach suchen.
Ohne das man Monka Tost.
Ore CLI.
Was ist Ore?
Infrastruck.
Ne das ist Ori.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
You can mine from anywhere.
Es ist Crypto Stelz.
AI.
Hier ist es ja.
Eine NeoWim Distribution.
Availab.
Okay.
Da kann ich mir auch nichts darunter vorstellen.
Was das sein soll.
Ja das ist immer die beste Idee Chat.
Mit Abstand die beste Idee.
Man weiß nicht was es ist.
Man hat keine Ahnung.
Keine Description.
Das Ding downloaden und nach Bash pipen.
Das ist definitiv the way.
Wie man das machen sollte.
Asudo davor noch.
Ist das irgendwelche Stonks Notifications?
Oder was?
Okay ich hab absolut keine Ahnung was es ist.
Ein langes Bash.
Großes Bash Skript.
Das ist garantiert irgendwelche Stonks Geschichten.
Oder Crypto Kram.
Das ist immer geil.
Wenn die Projekte keine Beschreibung haben.
Und du nicht weißt was es eigentlich sein soll.
Avail Project.
Das ist bestimmt auch irgendwelche Crypto Shit oder?
Ja okay Modular.
Blockchain.
AI.
Fireship.
Windows Image für.
Ja wie gesagt.
Das ist nicht Windows in Docker.
Das ist eigentlich Gbait was da steht.
Es ist.
KVM passt through in Docker.
Und darin dann Windows starten.
Aber es ist bestimmt Convenient.
Die Awesome List of Awesome Lists.
Alles klar.
Ach ne. Self Hosted.
AI.
Javascript Zeug.
Was trendet denn da für komisches Zeug?
Ach ich habe nur für Today.
Deswegen trendet da so merkwürdiger Kram.
Okay AI.
Find ich besser.
Redis.
Oder? Ja.
Das ist der.
Einer der Redis Forks.
Ich habe schon wieder vergessen.
Es gibt drei relativ.
Aktive Redis Forks.
Das ist einer davon.
Ja Redis hat sich selbst.
Auch so ein bisschen.
Wie soll man das nett ausdrücken.
Ins Knie gefickt so.
Die haben sich auch ein bisschen.
Selbst das.
Den Ast abgesägt so.
Auf der anderen Seite.
Die.
Wahrscheinlich.
So.
Tief die Redis Dependency.
Haben.
Und da wahrscheinlich auch Bock drauf haben.
Sogar Support zu kaufen.
Dass die sich damit doch noch ein bisschen.
Die goldene Nase verdienen.
Die Redis Leute.
War jemals.
Jemand von euch auf der Cubecon in Paris?
Nein.
Wirst du dir einen neuen OLED Monitor holen?
Da hat mir aber das Gesamtpaket noch nicht gefallen.
Es sieht aber immer mehr.
Danach aus dass es so langsam aber weiter.
Da ist ja.
Richtig nice Refresh Rates.
Die ja eh schon bei OLEDs.
Richtig nice sind.
Also die.
Eigentliche.
Die eigentliche Latency.
Bei OLEDs ist ja schon relativ gering.
Und jetzt gibt es.
Aber auch welche mit super nicer Refresh Rate.
Also es wird immer wahrscheinlicher.
Aber aktuell bin ich mit dieser.
Mit der 240 Hertz Kiste hier noch ganz.
Ganz zufrieden.
Den werde ich erstmal noch ein bisschen benutzen.
Aber es wird immer wahrscheinlicher.
Da ich mir einen OLED Monitor kaufe.
Ok AI.
AI.
Money Printer Turbo.
Da kannst du YouTube mit noch mehr Shit floaten.
AI.
Champ.
Moment das klingt ja fast wie als ist was von mir.
Das ist AI.
AI.
China Chinesen Zeug.
One Person Business.
Ah für das richtige Crimeset Mindset.
Nochmal JavaScript.
Machine Learning.
AI.
Ok ganz ehrlich ich glaube das waren so ziemlich die langweiligsten Github Trends.
Der letzten Monate die wir uns.
Die wir gesehen haben.
Da war ja gar nichts.
Das war ja echt.
Gar nichts.
Null spannendes dabei.
Das ist eine gute Frage Chat.
Gibt das mal an euch weiter.
Ist Burn-In noch ein Problem bei OLEDs?
Also ganz ehrlich.
Ich kann das nur noch von alten Röhrenmonitoren kennen.
Da wurde auch immer gesagt.
Oh Burn-In. Burn-In.
Ich hatte nie einen richtigen nervigen Burn-In.
Selbst in einem Röhrenmonitor.
Wo auch immer alle gesagt haben.
Ich weiß nicht wie das bei OLEDs ist.
Ob die dafür anfälliger sind.
Oder ob das wirklich.
Eher so ein.
Hörensagen Problem ist.
So.
Ja das kann passieren.
Aber keiner hat das bisher.
Also ich weiß nicht.
Du hattest das mal vor 5 Jahren.
Ok.
Also ich hatte das damals auch bei keinem meiner Röhrenmonitore.
Da haben sie auch immer gesagt damals.
Oh musst du aufpassen das es nicht einbrennt.
Das ist ja der Ursprung dieser ganzen Bildschirmschoner.
Die es damals gab.
Heute benutzt niemand mehr Bildschirmschoner.
Das ist komplett outdated.
Overrated.
Bildschirmschoner.
Aber damals war Bildschirmschoner so eine richtige Industrie.
Da hatte jeder versucht.
Den cooleren Bildschirmschoner zu haben.
Manche Leute hatten einen Angel-Bildschirmschoner.
Manche hatten irgendwie.
Der Klassiker ist natürlich.
Den gibt es glaube ich.
Auch für Linux.
Pipes.
Screen Saver.
Guck mal.
Sogar für die Shell.
Pass auf ja.
Pipes.
Also.
Der Windows 95.
Gab es den halt in 3D.
Aber den hatte jeder mal irgendwann.
Das ist jetzt halt nur mit ASCII Zeichen.
Das funktioniert nicht so ganz so gut.
Ihr erinnert euch noch oder?
Windows Pipes.
Das Teil.
Und man war damals.
Total fasziniert davon.
Wie advanced das alles ist.
Und so 3D.
Und überhaupt.
Was macht das passive Einkommen von deinem Fahrrad?
Was?
Das ist irgendwie ein Satz der absolut keinen Sinn ergibt.
Was wahrscheinlich Absicht ist.
Ja das Labyrinth war auch nice.
Mit den 2D Wänden.
Habe ich noch die Windows 95 VM?
Jawoll.
Wir können es uns doch live angucken.
Leute.
Ich bin aus MEVM.
Maces.
Jawoll.
Das war der Shit damals.
Mit den 2D Wänden.
Ich habe damals echt gedacht.
Die Zukunft ist angebrochen.
Als ich das gesehen habe.
Und das andere.
Was halt auch.
Das hier.
Das war so beliebt damals.
Und jeder der das gesehen hat.
Boah Alter.
Das hätte ich heute schon können.
Hä?
Das war eher so Windows 311 oder sowas.
Leonardo da Vinci.
Schwachsinn man.
Übrigens Outlook Express.
Legit immer noch besser als die Windows Mail App.
Gibt es die Windows Mail App noch?
Oder ist die mal schon wieder durch was neues ersetzt worden?
Boah Leute.
Ich bin ein bisschen kaputt irgendwie.
Ich war gestern knapp 3 Stunden Fahrrad fahren.
Heute kleine Runde Rennen.
30 Minuten.
Ach stimmt.
Es gibt doch jetzt Web Outlook.
Das neue Outlook ist doch irgendwie so Browser basiert jetzt.
Das habe ich.
Da habe ich auch schon von gehört.
Und bin ich mal gespannt.
Wann die das bei uns auf der Arbeit ersetzen.
Weil bei uns haben die ja total viele.
Zusatz Outlook Plugins und so.
Die dann wahrscheinlich nicht mehr funktionieren.
Ich bin jedes mal froh.
Wenn ich sowas sehe.
Dass ich mit der Windows Welt nichts zu tun habe.
Und ich frage mich immer weiterhin.
Um Microsoft da einzusetzen.
Outlook ist sicherlich noch eines der
brauchbareren Sachen.
Was die haben.
Wie bekommst du deinem...
Ja auch über Outlook.
Aber ich lese das meistens nicht in Outlook.
Sondern auf dem Handy.
Weil ich Outlook so unglaublich beschissen finde.
Da ist mir die
iOS Default Mail App
ja lieber als Outlook.
Einladung und Kalender
gucke ich prinzipiell nur noch über Teams.
Ja Outlook geht schon noch.
Aber ganz ehrlich.
Ich finde Outlook einfach so abartig nervig.
Findest auch nichts.
Die Suche ist beschissener
als die Amazon Suche.
Ja Thunderbird ist auch nicht
der Weisheit letzter Schluss.
Es gibt irgendwie keine richtig guten Mail Clients.
Aber Thunderbird geht schon noch.
Wenn man wirklich die reine Mail
Funktionalität braucht.
Wisst ihr was ich nicht verstehe?
Warum es in dem Fall
nicht einfach.
Einen ordentlichen Web Client gibt.
Sowas wie Google Mail.
Das ist auch nicht perfekt.
Kann fast nichts.
Aber das was es kann ist vollkommen ausreichend.
Und fertig.
Einfach eine Web Interface.
Ich weiß Outlook hat sowas.
Aber es ist immer noch kacke.
Und
einfach links die Ordner.
Rechts die E-Mail. Fertig.
Wo man halt aber auch gescheit
drinnen suchen kann.
Suche ist für mich legit das wichtigste in dem E-Mail Programm.
Weil ich bekomme
so viele E-Mails.
Und ignoriere 90% davon.
Und wenn dann doch mal einer sagt.
Ey Max guck mal da gab es doch eine Mail.
Da muss ich es halt suchen können.
Und mit der Outlook Suche findest du nichts.
Ja Windows Suche ist auch was was ich 0 0 benutze.
Weil es einfach nicht funktioniert.
Man kann es ja nicht ganz ausschalten.
Aber ich habe so weit ausgeschaltet wie geht.
Benachrichtigung habe ich aus.
Wenn ich Benachrichtigungen kriegen würde.
Jedes mal wenn ich eine Mail bekomme.
Wenn ich alle 30 Sekunden irgendwie
das Handy bimmeln habe.
Ich kenne das.
Bringt mir aber auf der Arbeit nichts.
Insgesamt ist es jetzt nicht schlecht.
Ich habe den sogar mal testweise installiert gehabt.
So.
Was können wir uns auf Youtube angucken.
Was ist denn hier schönes.
Leute heute Nachmittag
bauen wir unser ZigBee
Thermometer
Temperatursensor weiter.
Muss mal funktionieren.
Ok.
Was ist denn hier.
Oh ne.
Den gucken wir uns nicht an.
Das ist der Kubernetes Typ.
Mit dem Kubernetes Zeug daheim.
So optimierst du dein WLAN ja gar nicht.
Also.
Das einfachste das WLAN zu optimieren.
Ok doch.
Ein bisschen was kann man tatsächlich machen.
Das einfachste sein WLAN zu optimieren ist erstmal.
Die Access Points an einem sinnvollen Ort aufstellen.
Die meisten Leute.
Also ich.
Bestes Beispiel.
Ehemaliger Arbeitskollege hat mir das erzählt.
Bei sich daheim gibt es immer Stress wegen WLAN.
Warum gibt es Stress wegen WLAN.
Weil seine Frau.
Möchte die Fritzbox.
Nicht offen auf.
Nicht offen stehen haben in der Wohnung.
Weil das ist ja ein technisches Gerät und hat Kabel.
Das ist eh sowas.
Da würde ich persönlich komplette Anfälle kriegen.
Bei dieser Aussage.
Man muss halt manchmal auch Kompromisse machen.
Ja.
Zumindest.
Am Ende haben sie die Fritzbox.
Am Rand der Wohnung.
Stehen.
Ne am Rand des Hauses.
Am Rand des Hauses.
Hinter einer Wand.
Quasi von einem Schrank versteckt.
Und das ganze steht jetzt nicht horizontal.
Sondern hängt vertikal so dahinter.
Das sie keine Kabel sehen muss.
Problem ist jetzt halt.
Wenn sie unten an der Tür stehen.
Haben sie keinen gescheiten WLAN Empfang.
Das finden sie auch kacke.
Also am besten ist.
Man guckt sich mal an.
Wo man die Access Points am besten hinstellt.
Und dann.
Sollte man sich angucken.
Wie rum man die Access Points hinstellt.
Weil.
Es gibt Access Points.
Die sind gemacht für.
Einfach auf den Tisch legen.
Horizontal.
Gutes.
Es gibt Access Points.
Die sind gemacht für die Wandmontage.
Und Access Points.
Sind tatsächlich gemacht für Deckenmontage.
Das heißt nicht.
Das man die nicht auf die Erde stellen kann.
Oder das man die nicht vertikal irgendwo hin machen kann.
Geht auch.
Aber es ist manchmal sinnvoll sich das anzugucken.
Für was die Dinger gemacht sind.
Und dann sich zu überlegen.
Wo kann man die hin machen.
Und nach Möglichkeit.
Dann so das sie eben.
Das größte Gebiet abdecken.
Von dem Kegel.
Da gibt es meistens so Diagramme.
Oder nennt man das Diagramme.
So Maps gibt es da.
Für die jeweiligen Access Points.
Die zeigen wie die Dinger abstrahlen.
Und so Auswirkungen haben.
Und da kann man gucken wie man das hinstellt.
Also der Aufstellort.
Und wie man es hinhängt ist entscheidend.
Und manchmal ist es auch einfach sinnvoll.
Wenn man ein Haus hat zum Beispiel.
Zwei Access Points.
Wo hinzustellen.
Ja ich habe mich lange Zeit.
Dagegen gesträubt.
Als wir hier eingezogen sind.
2013.
Habe ich auch nen ollen Access Point hingestellt.
Das ging damals noch ganz gut.
Das war so ein ganz alter.
Also als wir 2013 hier eingezogen sind.
Hatte ich noch so nen.
So nen ganz alten.
Wartet mal.
Das war noch.
Das war so outdated WiFi Zeug.
Linksys oder so.
Irgendein Linksys.
Ne.
Keine Ahnung.
Wenn ihr das 2006 oder so mal gekauft habt.
Das ist ewig.
Zumindest.
Ich finde das jetzt nicht.
So ein Ding wo man noch OpenWrt drauf installieren kann.
Ne.
Keine Ahnung.
Irgend so ein ganz alter Access Point.
Super langsam.
Den hatte ich hier oben bei mir in den Serverraum gestellt.
Und es hat wunderbar funktioniert.
Oh nein.
Schon wieder Postleitzahl liegt.
Es hat wunderbar funktioniert.
Da hast du irgendwie was.
Ja.
Kann durchaus sein.
Ne.
Der war das nicht.
Irgend so ein alter Linksys.
Old Access Point.
Kann man danach suchen bei Amazon.
Gibt es hier gar nicht mehr.
Zumindest.
Aber ungefähr so alt.
Ungefähr so alt wie das Teil.
Und das war alt und lahm.
Und kacke.
Weil umso lahmer das WLAN.
Sagen wir mal.
Umso besser die Reichweite.
Da hast du nur ein paar Mbit.
Und das hat das ganze Haus abgedeckt.
Als das Ding hier bei mir im Serverraum gestanden hat.
Easy. Gar kein Problem.
Und dann habe ich irgendwann mal.
Ich glaube sogar.
Einfach von der Fritzbox damals das WLAN benutzt.
Und da habe ich festgestellt.
Ey. Der Empfang.
Ist schon ein bisschen kacke.
Also das hat beispielsweise.
Den Hof nicht mehr abgedeckt.
Und man hatte im Keller.
Keinen richtigen Empfang.
Man hatte teilweise unten im Wohnzimmer.
Probleme und so.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht.
Ey. Ich habe jetzt eigentlich gedacht.
WLAN technisch wird alles besser und schneller.
Ist aber nicht so.
Bis es dann irgendwann gedämmert ist.
Okay. Je schneller das WLAN ist.
Umso problematischer sind Wände dazwischen.
Und umso schlechter ist die Reichweite.
In der Regel.
Sagen wir mal.
5 GHz WLAN besser durch Wände durch.
Als 5 GHz.
Und dann habe ich angefangen damals.
Unify Access Points hier hinzustellen.
Das war ein bisschen besser.
Allerdings hatte ich das Problem.
Das.
Es sinnvoll gewesen wäre.
Beispielsweise auf.
Die andere Seite des Hauses was zu stellen.
Und das ging nicht gescheit.
Weil ich dort kein.
Netzwerkkabel hatte.
Da konnte man quasi nur.
WLAN zu WLAN.
So. Nicht so geil.
Übrigens das steht auch noch an.
Das müssen wir unbedingt im Stream machen.
OpenWrt Flaschen auf meine alten Ubiquiti.
Access Points.
So. Und.
Wie ich mein WLAN Problem jetzt endgültig gefixt habe.
Ist folgendes.
Ich habe mir gebrauchte.
RUCUS Access Points gekauft.
Auf Ebay.
Und ich habe jetzt einen.
Also die hier.
Die Dinger.
Also lasst euch vom Preis nicht schocken.
Die habe ich jetzt auch schon glaube.
Die habe ich vor Corona schon am Start gehabt.
Also bestimmt auch schon jetzt 3 Jahre oder.
Wann war Corona? 3 Jahre.
So und das Teil.
Habe ich.
Bei mir jetzt oben ins Wohnzimmer gehängt.
Und zwar an die Decke.
So wie sich das gehört.
Im ersten Stock im Wohnzimmer an die Decke.
Und dann habe ich noch einen.
Im Keller.
Dort wo ich Netzwerkkabel habe mit PoE.
Im Keller habe ich noch einen stehen.
Und seitdem.
Ist die WLAN Abdeckung.
Jetzt vielleicht nicht 100% perfekt.
Also in den Garten.
Kannst du nicht gehen damit.
Also das ist nicht alles so.
Es ist nicht komplett.
Überall perfekt.
Aber du bekommst überall wo es drauf ankommt.
Empfang und hast keine Probleme.
Bei dem Shop habe ich auch schon ein paar Sachen gekauft.
Die sind gar nicht schlecht für Netzwerkgeräte.
Und seitdem.
Ist es gefixt.
Ein im Keller.
Ein im Wohnzimmer im ersten Stock.
Ganzes Haus damit abgedeckt.
Inklusive Hof.
Und theoretisch auch die Straße noch.
Ein bisschen wenn man davor steht.
Warum die so teuer sind.
Weil das Business
Stonks Enterprise Kram ist.
Die sind aber auch schon ein bisschen outdated.
Also das sind ja nur AC.
Access Points.
Aktuell sind wir ja schon bei.
Bei was sind wir jetzt eigentlich.
AX ist doch auch schon wieder outdated oder.
Was ist denn das neue.
Wir sind doch jetzt schon.
Bei mindestens Wifi.
Wifi 6e.
Und die sind doch teilweise schon bei Wifi 7 jetzt.
Ah.
802.11be.
Sind wir jetzt.
Ok und was hat Wifi 6e.
Für eine Standardnummer.
Ok das ist immer noch Teil von AX.
Alles klar.
Hast du Erfahrung mit Sicherheitskameras.
Ja habe ich.
Ich habe schon mal ein Stück.
Verteilt.
Kann auch kein Gerät.
Es sind aber keine guten teuren.
Das sind so China Chinesen.
Kameras mit RTSP Verbindung.
Die aber günstig sind und ganz brauchbar funktionieren.
Und keine Cloud brauchen.
Und keine App brauchen und sowas.
Ja also das sind nur AC.
Nur AC Access Points.
Heißt auch wenn ich jetzt einen Speedtest mache.
Ist es nicht so berauschend.
Ich mach mal kurz einen Speedtest.
Warte mal kurz vor dem Handy.
So weit weg vom Access Point.
Also die Verbindung ist ganz gut hier.
Go Speedtest.
Ich bekomme.
90.
92, 93, 94.
Ja.
97, 103.
103 Mbit ungefähr.
Bekomme ich hier über das Wlan.
Kann man jetzt sagen ist ja kacke.
Aber seriously.
Wen juckt's.
Ich nehm lieber 100 Mbit.
Ich mein 100 Mbit.
Ist immer noch genug.
Was sind denn 100 Mbit?
25.
25 MB oder sowas.
Kannste alles streamen.
Und dir angucken was du brauchst.
Ganz ehrlich ich nehm lieber 100 Mbit.
Mit Empfang auf dem kompletten Grundstück.
Plus ein Stückchen drüber raus.
Plus im Keller.
Plus unter dem Dach.
Erdgeschoss Terrasse bis Eingang vom Garten.
Anstatt.
Ein viel komplexeres Setup.
Noch Kabel legen.
Und neue Access Points.
Und massig Kohle und Stress.
Und dafür dann halt schneller.
Ey wie komm ich auf 25 MB.
Also mein.
Irgendwas kann ja nicht ganz so falsch bei mir im Kopf sein.
Wenn ich genau das doppelte sage.
Wie komm ich denn auf 25 MB.
Macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Es müssen.
12,5 sein.
Ja weil.
100 Gigabit ist 125.
Ja.
Na gut muss man sagen.
Mit 12,5 MB.
Wenn man jetzt.
Auf dem Handy beispielsweise.
Irgendwelches.
4K Material gucken möchte.
Was.
Richtig.
Richtig heftig.
Ja nicht komprimiert quasi ist.
Oder wenig komprimiert.
Dann könntest vielleicht.
Noch mehr als genug.
Ich mein.
Die krassesten Youtube Videos.
In höchster Auflösung.
Was haben die.
40 MBit oder sowas.
Und das bringt ja auf dem kleinen.
Handybildschirm eh nix.
Jo.
Also.
Ich bin damit.
Eigentlich ganz zufrieden.
Und sobald es auf Ebay.
Mal die.
Was auch immer das war.
Wenn es die Nachfolger gibt.
Rokus.
Weil es auf Ebay mal die Nachfolger gibt.
Die sind aktuell noch ein bisschen.
Vielleicht ein bisschen.
Teuer.
Dann hole ich mir die.
Was ich an denen übrigens ganz nice.
Finde ist.
Die laufen ohne Controller.
Im Vergleich zu den Ubiquiti Dingern.
Die irgendeinen Raspberry Pi beispielsweise.
Als Controller brauchen.
Womit ich auch.
Das hat mich so abgefuckt.
Auf der einen Seite.
Sich vermarktet hat.
Für Noobs.
Auf der anderen Seite.
Aber nicht noobisch genug war.
Ganz weird state.
Das Ubiquiti Zeug.
Und.
Die finde ich ganz gut.
Da macht einer der Access Points den Controller mit.
Die haben genug Power.
Und das Web Interface ist auch ganz okay.
Ja und die Dinger haben ein Feature.
Was ich ja schon immer haben wollte.
Und zwar.
Unterschiedliche Passwörter.
Unterschiedliche WLAN Passwörter.
Für unterschiedliche Geräte.
Also das beispielsweise.
Mein Handy ein anderes WLAN Passwort bekommt.
Als mein Drucker.
Beispielsweise ein anderes WLAN Passwort bekommt.
Als die smarte Glühbirne.
Oder irgendwie der Stromzähler.
Das jedes Gerät.
Ein eigenes WLAN Passwort bekommen kann.
Das ist enorm.
Pock.
Die Access Points können.
Leider konnte das Ubiquiti nicht.
Bis die letzte Version.
Ich glaube mittlerweile geht das.
Radius bringt dir ja nichts.
Wenn es die Geräte nicht können.
Wenn die Geräte kein Enterprise Wifi können.
Wie auch immer das genau heißt.
Dann bringt dir das nichts.
Ja.
So sieht es aus.
Und seitdem ich das jetzt habe.
Seit ein paar Jahren bin ich echt zufrieden.
Überhaupt keine WLAN Probleme und nichts.
Ne musst du gar nicht.
Wenn du die Dinger auf Ebay kaufst.
Dann sind die.
Also du kannst dir die Dinger günstiger.
Auf Ebay kaufen.
Die stehen dann allerdings auf US.
Und US.
Geräte sind ja eigentlich nicht.
Für den Export gemacht.
Das heißt du kannst da einige Sachen nicht einstellen.
Die wichtig sind für.
Deutschland.
Was aber kein Problem ist.
Weil es gibt auf GitHub.
Eine Anleitung.
Wie man die umflaschen kann.
Hast du Erfahrung mit Sicherheitskameras.
Kannst du welche empfehlen.
Also.
Ich würde nicht so weit gehen.
Dass ich die empfehlen kann.
Weil die sind alles andere als problemlos.
Die muss man beispielsweise ab und zu mal neu starten.
Aber insgesamt.
Für den Preis funktionieren die ganz gut.
Ich habe eine Mischung aus billigen.
Reolink Kameras.
Outdoor.
Ja.
Solchen Dingern hier.
Man muss aufpassen welche man sich kauft.
Weil manche gehen nur über den ihre Cloud.
Und manche haben ganz klassisch noch.
POE.
Oder Wifi.
Und RTSP Streams.
Also da muss man genau gucken was man sich kauft.
WA ist glaube ich welche die nur mit Cloud.
Da muss man echt aufpassen was man da kauft.
Also ich habe welche die gehen alle.
Lokal über Wifi oder Netzwerk.
Und dann per RTSP den Stream abgreifen.
Also von denen habe ich.
Von denen habe ich ein paar günstige Kameras.
Das sind nicht die geilsten Kameras ever.
Die haben schon ihre Macken.
Aber die gehen für den Preis.
Echt ganz gut.
Und sie brauchen keine Cloud.
Und sie brauchen keine China Chinesen App.
Wie gesagt.
Man muss aber genau gucken was man sich kauft.
Dass man die Serie kauft mit lokalem Stream.
Dann habe ich noch ein paar alte.
Wisecams.
Noch die V1er glaube ich.
Die alten.
Oder V2er.
Ja.
Noch.
Und noch die kleine.
Ja.
Und die kleine noch.
Die habe ich im Keller hängen.
Damit ich mir den Druck.
In der Heizung angucken kann.
Die macht nichts anderes wie den Druck von der Heizung filmen.
Mir schwebt schon seit einer ganzen.
Weile vor.
Wie man das nicht vielleicht.
Automatisieren könnte.
Aber ich habe noch keine AI gefunden.
Die eine gescheite.
Detection.
Und sie ist gerade mal so ein.
Nadel auf so einer Druck Anzeige.
Hinbekommt.
Insofern gucke ich halt einfach auf das Kamerabild.
Ja.
Und dann habe ich noch eine Raspberry Pi Kamera.
Am Start.
Das ist so meine Kombination.
Also macht dann insgesamt.
Lass mal überlegen.
Keller.
Flur.
Katzenklo.
Wobei ich die habe ich zwar noch an.
Hof, Eingang, sechs Stück, ja.
Warum pastest du permanent irgendeinen Kerl?
Dann mach mal Ausrufezeichen 1 im Chat, da erkläre ich das.
Ja, so sieht es aus mit meinen Kameras.
Und wie ich die ganze Sache übertrage, ist, also ich zeichne nichts auf.
Ich benutze das nur zum Gucken.
Beispielsweise, wenn es klingelt, ob es Hermes oder DHL ist, die vor der Tür stehen.
Oder ob es mein Vater ist, dass ich faken kann, dass ich nicht daheim bin.
Je nachdem, dass ich sehe, wer vor der Tür steht.
Oder, ja, um auf die Terrasse zu gucken, Hof oder sonst was.
Also ich zeichne nichts auf von meinen Kameras.
Das heißt, da habe ich keinen Bedarf.
Ich hätte aber trotzdem ganz gerne relativ latencyfreies Streaming in den Browser.
Und dazu habe ich mir selbst was programmiert.
Was den RTSP-Stream abgreift und per WebRTC in den Browser schickt.
Weil ich nichts gefunden habe, was das wirklich gut kann.
Es gibt zig Projekte auf GitHub, die angeblich das können.
Und vielleicht liegt es auch an meinen Billig-Kameras, dass die nicht ordentlich funktionieren.
Aber außer mein selbstprogrammiertes funktioniert da nichts von gescheit.
Übrigens, Leute, das ist das, was wir uns letztens im Stream zusammen angeguckt haben.
Wo ich dachte, ich habe eine Memory-Leak.
Ich habe keine Memory-Leak, Leute.
Ich habe irgendwo ein...
Problem, weil das Ding ab und zu crasht.
So alle 3-4 Stunden crasht das mal.
Mit Segmentation-Fault.
Und das muss irgendeine C-Interop-Sache sein, die crasht.
Und ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, an welcher Stelle ich nicht aufgepasst habe und warum das crasht.
Nullplan.
Ich vermute, es liegt an FFmpeg.
Aber ich sehe keinen Fehler in meinem FFmpeg-Programmabschnitt.
Das ist gut, das zu sagen.
Mir fällt gerade auf, dass FFmpeg und Frankfurter Main die gleichen Anfangsbuchstaben als Abkürzung haben.
Welchen Router nutzt du?
Also.
Ich benutze ein...
Mikrotik...
Hex-PoE.
Schon seit Jahren habe ich das Ding.
Nichts tolles, aber günstig.
Und mit RouterOS so ziemlich das umfangreichste an Konfigurationen, was man sich vorstellen kann.
...
Also eins muss man echt sagen.
Die WLAN-Konfiguration habe ich glaube ich noch nirgendwo so beschissen gesehen wie in RouterOS.
WLAN-Konfiguration kann super einfach sein, aber unter RouterOS ist das echt eine Wissenschaft für sich.
Das Ding habe ich als Router am Start.
Aktuell sieht die Bestückung so aus.
Einmal Uplink zu Vodafone.
Vodafone-Box ist hier.
dran dann ist ja also das hier geht zu einem switch also das hier um es genau sein das hier
geht in die fritz box erzähle ich kein mist nee das hier geht direkt in die vodafone box und an
der vodafone box selbst steckt auch noch eine fritz box dran die web und decktelefon und so
was macht ja ich habe auch noch zwei decktelefone die fritz box macht auch noch home assistant
connection zu meinen thermostaten und so was also eine fritz box ran wenn ich jetzt fragt warum hast
du eine unity media box und eine fritz box dann ist die antwort weil ich zu faul bin bisher das
umzustellen man kann ja ohne probleme bei vodafone sagen ich schalte meine eigene fritz box frei und
ich habe mir sogar mal vor einem dreiviertel jahr eine neue fritz box gekauft um das alles in
kombination zu machen aber ich war bisher zu faul das umzustellen also man könnte ein gerät einsparen
an der stelle
ja hier an den poe anschlüssen sind die zwei access points dran wobei nur für ein access point
poe verwendet wird der andere access point hat so einen power injector da braucht es einfach nur
netzwerk und an dem anderen hängt der interne switch dran als interner switch habe ich ein
es16 xg 10 gig switch so ein teil das teil sieht man auch bei mir egal egal
welches welches man nimmt er gut hier war ein bisschen sehr dreckig alles sieht man auch das
ding hier den da unten hängt da ist das switch ja das habe ich als router muss ich das aus angenommen
ich habe einen ubuntu server ist portier nein ich mag portena nicht docker compose ist nicht
verkehrt aber also ich persönlich mag portena überhaupt gar nicht
ich finde docker compose yaml files an sich nicht verkehrt muss sich halt per ssh drauf
connecten oder was ich auch ganz nice das projekt finde für den heimbereich wohlgemerkt ausschließlich
ist das ding da kannst du zwar viele sachen gar nicht einstellen die du mit portena einstellen
kannst aber irgendwie habe ich die übelste abneigung gegen portena das im prinzip nur
den web frontend um docker compose files starten und zu stoppen das finde ich auch ganz nice
ansonsten ssh drauf docker compose ab down fertig ich mag portena nicht ich weiß viele benutzen
das gerne ich kann meine abneigung gegenüber portena auch gar nicht richtig begründen ehrlich
gesagt an mir widerstrebt einfach enorm haben wir irgendwelche portena enjoyers oder haters im chat
und wenn ja warum
ja genau touring pi 2.0
im chat und wenn ja warum ja genau touring pi 2.0
touring pi 2.0
0 wenn ich nicht dass irgendwas für ein raspberry pi ach nee das ist das ist quasi im board um
mehrere raspberry pi drauf zu klipsen wirst dich nicht wozu ja also ganz ehrlich du meinst wlan
config end in router us ja das ist auch sowas von dumm gemacht ich weiß nicht was mit mikrotik da
los ist normalerweise würde ich sagen china chinesen software aber mikrotik kommt nicht
aus china ich glaube die kommen aus bulgarien oder sowas oder aus polen oder wo kommt mikrotik
her ungarn kommen die her lettland okay ich habe gar nichts gesagt lettland litowner ist okay was
kann man selbst mal auf youtube angucken erstmal schauen nein nein das kann ich mir jetzt nicht
geben haben wir denn hier so ok ich habe jetzt so lange über wlan gelegt wir kommen uns jetzt
an wie man seinen wlan optimist schon mal schauen wir mal wie man sein wlan optimist
schau mal hier ich schaue mal hier guck guck mal hier ja guck mal hier das ist
alter wie lange habe ich in dieses game nicht mehr gesehen das ist noch aus beauty
pilots play zeiten ich habe sogar vergessen wie hießen dieser krempe noch mal wie hießen
das was jeder letzt player damals irgendwie letzt played hat qw op ist das so ja so
es ist nicht ich musste gerade was lesen auf dem bildschirm okay
bevor du dieses video gesehen hast und so könnte dein wlan nach ein paar minuten optimierung ja ja
ganz bestimmt das war ganz ganz bestimmt also ich finde den ich finde den channel
gut deswegen geben wir ihm also dem vorschuss lorbeeren das jetzt auch was gescheites kommt
bei den normalen videos dieser art ist das am ende meistens auch nicht besser als davor aber
es ist ein bisschen wie diese diese tricks von früher aus den zeitschriften mit diesen sachen so
irgendwie 95 geheime windows hex und sowas ich manchmal ruckeln netflix streams oder ihr habt
einen sauschlechten ping bei fortnite oder sonst in diesem video gehen wir mal ein paar ganz konkrete
tipps durch wie man das repariert also wie gesagt aus meiner sicht der aufstellort für die router ist
wie rum man sie aufstellt, dass man sie richtig
aufstellt, zum Router passend
eventuell, also Access Point, jetzt fange ich auch schon mit
dieser Router-Geschichte an, Access Point
aufstellt, wie sie gedacht sind
und dass man eventuell eben mehr als einen
Access Point im Haus verteilt, dort
wo es möglich ist, wegen
halt Kabel
und ansonsten, einzige
was du noch machen kannst, ist vielleicht ein bisschen
rumspielen mit den WLAN-Channels
wobei ich da die Erfahrung
gemacht habe, gerade die etwas besseren
wie es bei der Fritzbox ist, weiß ich nicht
ich benutze das WLAN an der Fritzbox nicht
haben da schon einen ganz guten
so Auto-Detection-Mode
für die Channels
gucken wir mal
mit Quality of Service
und potenziell geht 2,4 GHz
WLAN weiter als 5 GHz WLAN
kommt aber natürlich immer ein bisschen drauf an
wie viel noch so drumherum los
ist, auf den jeweiligen
Frequenzen
mit besserer Router-Platzierung oder zur Not
mit einem Repeater und wir zeigen euch auch
natürlich
wie es bei der Fritzbox ist
wie man den WLAN-Durchsatz am besten misst
nicht nur am Smartphone, sondern auch
am Desktop
IPR ist das beste
liebe Hackerin, liebe Internet-Server
herzlich willkommen hier
ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, ob die
Lautstärke stimmt
dieses Video wird gesponsert von Ugreen
Ugreen kennt ihr vielleicht von
Ugreen, das sind irgendwelche
China-Chinesen-Billig-Powerbanks
bei mir im Kopf
wie ist das bei euch?
...Ladegeräten oder USB-Adaptern
jetzt gibt es von dem Unternehmen auch
NAS-Systeme, das hier ist das
NA-SYNC
...ist das ein 3D gedrucktes Case?
...ich bilde mir ein, man sieht ein bisschen
Layer drauf
...kennst du den Mythos Alu-Folie
um die Router-Antenne zu packen
um die Reichweite zu hören?
ehrlich gesagt
also ich kenne
das ist schon Jahre her
ähm
ich könnte mir vorstellen
also ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt
ich muss gleich dazu sagen
ähm
ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen dass da
wenn man es richtig macht
macht eventuell was dran ist das ding ist nur und das kommt wo ich mir halt
wiederum echt nicht sicher bin ob das sinnvoll ist reichweite erhöhen bedeutet
bei funk eigentlich immer so ein bisschen richtwirkung einbauen und das
willst du in der regel bei wlan nicht weil dann hast du vielleicht in der
küche auf einmal super empfangen aber im badezimmer nicht mehr
also du willst wlan ja eigentlich so relativ ja kegel beziehungsweise fast
schon fast schon ein bisschen kugelförmig dass das abstrahlt ich glaube
das ist meistens keine so gute idee kann aber in einzelnen fällen bestimmt was
bewirken wenn man genau weiß was man macht und für diesen einen
anwendungsfall ja die kenne ich auch noch ich habe mal eine dvb t antenne
selbst gebaut
dvb t antenne selbst bauen ist richtig easy gewesen man hat einfach so ein
altes moment dvb t antenne anleitung gibt das ist advanced da das ist
deutlich advanced das was ich damals gemacht habe
man konnte nämlich einfach diese so ein altes antennen kabel nehmen und die
antennenkabel ja hier sowas in der so was in der richtung genau ja man hat
einfach das alte antennenkabel
kabel genommen und hat die isolierung aufgemacht und hat die hat also diese
quasi dieses dieses dieses geflecht was da drin ist umgestülpt
das musste genau ja irgendwie 41 zentimeter sein und da vorne der tag
muss irgendwie genauer 10 bis 4 das hat was mit der wellenlänge von dvb t zu
tun und er hatte mal so eine hässliche selbstgebauten antenne dran die echt
ganz gut funktioniert hat die xp 4800 plus das kommt mit einem intel pensium
gold 8505 prozessor mit 8 gb ram der auf 64 gb erweitert und hat ein ich gebe
mal kurz sondern bleiben bei euch zu hause dann könnt ihr einfach hier nach
bildern suchen zum beispiel mit jetzt geht's los mit wlan vorab erstmal die
meisten tipps hier in diesem video sind allgemeingültig also das klappt generell
mit so gut wie allen wlan-routern wir zeigen aber nur die konkreten 1
chat
router oder router stellungsoptionen von fritz boxen weil die marktanteil also
je nachdem wo man danach schaut von bis zu zwei dritteln haben ich persönlich
bin auch in der fraktion router aber gerade aber gerade so netzwerkexperten
und hauptsächlich aus dem cisco bereich stehen sehr auf router also die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass ihr zu hause eine fritz box habt ihr ist einfach hoch und
ja
fangen wir an nummer eins liefert die leitung überhaupt was versprochen ist
der wichtigste punkt der die download und upload geschwindigkeit in eurem
wlan-netz bestimmt ist die leitung selbst also euer internet tarif ja in der
anbieter ist klar den megabit pro sekunde liefert ist das internet
langsamer als bei einer 250 megabit leitung also das ist der erste ja ja
das ist klar jetzt ja auch ein englisches wort also ist es dann auch
die route 66 oder es ist die route 66 ich habe da noch keine gute andere
Antwort drauf bekommen, warum es Router
sein sollte.
Zugegebenermaßen sehr offensichtliche
Optimierungspunkt. Schauen,
ob die gebuchte Leistung...
Ich hab's leider verpasst.
Das war letztens kostenlos auf Steam.
Da gab's wieder ein paar Noobs.
...an eurem Router ankommt.
Das könnt ihr euch in der Benutzeroberfläche
eures Routers ansehen. Die Benutzeroberfläche
selbst erreicht ihr über den Browser,
in dem ihr entweder...
Besser nicht fritz.box eingeben.
Wobei, die Domain wurde gesperrt, oder?
Ist die nicht weg mittlerweile?
Also für kurze Erklärung.
Es gibt jetzt mittlerweile
die Möglichkeit, sich .box
Domains zu kaufen.
Über irgendeine komische
Cryptocurrency
...
Verkaufsplattform.
Und
da hat sich irgendjemand
fritz.box
gekauft
als Domain.
Und da hatten viele Leute das Problem,
dass die auf irgendeiner komischen
Crypto-NFT-Seite rausgekommen sind,
wenn sie fritz.box eingegeben haben.
...P-Adresse eingebt
oder bei der fritz.box einfach fritz.box.
Das Passwort ist auf der Rückseite
des Routers aufgedrückt.
Ich hab hier bei mir zu Hause
einen 1-Gigabit-Anschluss gebucht,
also mit einem Gigabit down und...
Tja, wenn die es mal schaffen würden,
bei mir ordentlich Glasfaser auszubauen,
was drumherum überall passiert,
bloß bei mir irgendwie nicht,
dann hätte ich auch schon Gigabit.
Aber...
Wir wollen uns mal nicht beschweren.
400 Mbit ist auch okay.
50 Megabit upstream.
Und entsprechend zeigt es hier auch
1,15 Gigabit im down
und 56,7 Megabit im upstream an.
Warum ist eigentlich...
Ah, okay, das ist Kabel.
Das ist Kabel, okay.
Das ist Vodafone-Geschiss, ja, verstehe.
Weil Fiber-to-the-Home sollte eigentlich
nicht so einen krassen Unterschied haben,
Upload und Download.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
wie ist denn da so die Standardverteilung
Upload zu Download?
Also ich meine,
aus meiner Sicht macht es eigentlich wenig Sinn,
dass es überhaupt irgendwie noch
eine große unterschiedliche Verteilung gibt.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist es trotzdem so,
weil die Leute sind es gewöhnt,
also macht man es.
Ich hätte jetzt erwartet,
dass es dort halt irgendwie
einen Gigabit ab und einen Gigabit down gibt,
aber wahrscheinlich ist es nicht so.
Wahrscheinlich ist es ein Gigabit down
und, keine Ahnung, 500 ab oder...
Also ziemlich genau das,
was mir mein Provider zugesichert hat,
mit ein bisschen Puffer.
Alles in Ordnung also.
Falls da aber weniger steht,
als das, was ihr gebucht habt,
dann stimmt da womöglich Provider-seitig was nicht
und ihr solltet bei der Hotline anrufen.
Wenn ihr übrigens in dem Menü hier
auf Kabel oder DSL klickt,
also je nachdem,
wie das Internet bei euch ins Haus kommt,
seht ihr nochmal mehr Details.
So, aber erfahrungsgemäß
liegen die meisten WLAN-Probleme,
ja, am WLAN und nicht an der Internetleitung.
Deshalb Nummer 2,
Priorisierung der Datenpakete.
Was hier nämlich schon helfen könnte,
ihr könnt im Router-Menü
einer bestimmten Anwendung
Vorrang vor allen anderen geben.
Ja, das, ich meine,
man braucht das meistens nicht.
Das ist eher sowas,
was zum Tragen kommt,
wenn ordentlich Traffic
auf dem Netz gerade ist.
Also wenn die Leute irgendwie,
ja gerade irgendwie,
was weiß ich,
die Kinder gucken sich irgendwie Netflix an,
der Opa guckt auf dem Fernseher
auch irgendeinen Stream,
ja, einer guckt irgendwie YouTube
und alles Mögliche ist voll
und man möchte jetzt möglichst
latency-free irgendwas machen,
dann kann das schon was bringen.
In der Regel, wenn nicht viel Traffic
im Netzwerk ist,
macht diese ganze QoS-Geschichte
nicht viel Unterschied.
Zum Beispiel einfach ein Gerät
wie hier der Playstation
oder eurem Laptop.
Generell kann es sich lohnen,
genauer mit der Priorisierung,
also Quality of Service,
kurz QoS,
auseinanderzusetzen.
Gerade wenn ihr euren Internetanschluss
nicht alleine verwendet,
könnt ihr so genau festlegen,
welche Geräte und Dienste
welche Bandbreite benötigen.
Egal, ob ihr eine Fritzbox
oder einen anderen Router verwendet.
Wenn euer Router QoS unterstützt,
dann sind oft zumindest zwei Funktionen
ab Werk aktiv.
Die Priorisierung von Datenpaketen
für die VoIP-Telefonie
und da der Router nicht wissen kann,
welche Anwendung...
Also VoIP ist das,
was eigentlich immer priorisiert werden sollte,
wenn es mal irgendwie knapp wird
im Netzwerk.
Ja.
Weil VoIP ist halt
hörbar Echtzeit.
So.
Es macht keinen Sinn,
wenn da Pakete zu spät ankommen.
Die kannst du im Prinzip auch droppen,
weil...
Wie willst du...
Ja.
Sprache...
irgendwie gescheit,
lag-frei dann zu...
Also es funktioniert nicht.
Also entweder baust einen Buffer ein,
vor ein paar Sekunden,
was dann halt kacke ist,
mit deinem Gegenüber zu sprechen,
wenn jeder zwei, drei Sekunden Lag hat.
Funktioniert nicht richtig.
Also, ja, QoS bei VoIP macht schon immer Sinn.
Ja, das...
Wenn man nutzt und welche einem wichtig sind,
läuft der übrige Verkehr mit normaler Priorität.
Außerdem läuft in der FRITZ!Box ab Werk
noch eine dritte, aber sehr wichtige...
Analog-Telefonie war MVP.
Also in manchen Bereichen tatsächlich, ja.
Gerade was Ausfallsicherheit angeht,
war Analog-Telefonie wirklich MVP.
Priorisierung, nämlich die Priorisierung
der Quittungspakete für Downloads.
Die Faustregel lautet, ohne Quittung kein Download.
Und ja, je schneller die Quittung rausgeht,
desto besser nutzt ein Download die Empfangsrichtung.
Wenn du aber spezielle Anforderungen hast,
musst du die Einstellung selbst einstellen.
Nee, Leute, also...
Das stimmt nicht.
Moderne Audio-Codecs hören sich schon deutlich besser an,
als noch alles analoges Telefon.
Dafür bietet die FRITZ!Box drei Priorisierungsstufen.
Echtzeitanwendung, priorisierte Anwendung und Hintergrund.
Ja gut, das müssen wir uns jetzt eigentlich nicht angucken.
Wenn man das...
E-Mule.
Moment!
Warum ist das da noch drinne?
Ja, sind da Surfen, HTT...
Das kommt ja noch aus der antiken Zeit des Internets alles.
Was gab's denn da sonst noch?
Was hat man damals sonst noch so gehabt?
So Kazaar und sowas und...
Also das ist, das ist, das ist noch...
Das ist die Zeit nach Napster gewesen.
Napster war so das, was damals jeder kannte.
Aber das, das kam alles ein bisschen später.
Was gab's denn da sonst noch?
E-Mule gab's noch, ja.
Kazaar...
Was gab's denn da sonst noch so für Dinger?
Das ist schon so lang her.
Morpheus, Slimewire...
E-Dunkey!
Ja, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Das war das Ding, was irgendwie erst mal 58.000 Verbindungen aufgebaut hat
und dann nicht benutzt hat.
Das waren Zeiten, ne.
Da gab's noch Audio Galaxy und sowas damals.
Das ist ewig her.
Das ist bestimmt 20 Jahre, hä?
P-Server, FTP-Server, E-Mule...
Selbstverständlich hat man damals damit nur Linux-ISOs runtergeladen.
Logisch, was sonst, oder?
Also wir hätten doch niemals damit was anderes runtergeladen.
Wie viel das überhaupt bringt?
Im Regelfall wahrscheinlich gar nix, wenn nicht viel los ist im Netzwerk.
QoS bringt nur was, wenn's Stau gibt.
QoS heißt ja nichts anderes wie, wenn du jetzt zwei Pakete hast, die verschickt werden sollen,
aber das Netzwerk zu ausgelastet ist, dass man beide gleichzeitig verschicken kann,
oder, ja, nahezu gleichzeitig verschicken kann,
in welcher Priorisierung die Pakete verschickt werden.
Nix anderes macht QoS, ja.
Das können wir mal überspringen mit der Priorisierung.
...durchsatz messen und Router-Position.
Ja.
Das hab ich ja auch schon gesagt, Router-Position, das hilft was.
Das ist aber auch nach dem Priorisieren weiter in eurem WLAN-Netzwerk ruckelt.
Solltet ihr euer Netz in eurer Wohnung genauer anschauen bzw. messen,
dabei hilft euch die Fritz-WLAN-App.
Die gibt's für iOS und Android und die funktioniert auch mit Nicht-Fritz-Boxen,
also Routern, die nicht von AVM sind.
Also ich hab immer iPerf benutzt.
Natürlich ist das ein bisschen ekliger zu benutzen als das hier.
Ich finde das gar nicht so übel hier.
Weil vermutlich testet die keinen Internet-Speed,
sondern wirklich WLAN zu Fritz-Box und zurück und sowas.
Oder WLAN zu, tja.
Wobei, wenn das mit was anderem als Fritz-Boxen funktioniert,
muss das ja ins Internet, keine Ahnung, was die macht.
Also iPerf hat halt den Vorteil, du misst nicht deine Internetleitung,
sondern wirklich dein WLAN, dein Netzwerk-Speed daheim.
Einfach hier auf WLAN messen und lass das dann mindestens 30 Sekunden laufen.
Je höher die gelbe Linie verläuft, umso besser ist der Durchsatz,
umso niedriger die grüne Linie, umso kürzer ist die Latenz.
Also die Laufzeit von den Paketen zwischen Router und Smartphone.
Wenn die Linien mit Durchsatz und Latenz einigermaßen gerade verlaufen,
ist das erstmal gut.
Achso, die Latenz sollte...
Ich mach das jetzt auch mal kurz aufwendig.
Die Fritz-WLAN-App.
Wenn der Durchsatz arg stark hoch und runter geht,
dann ist das ein Zeichen dafür, dass beim WLAN was nicht so läuft, wie es soll.
Was man dann als erstes probieren sollte,
die Position des Routers verändern.
Ich hab schon mit eigenen Augen gesehen, dass Leute ihre...
Ich probier das jetzt mal aus.
Die Fritz...
Ich hab's ja vorhin ganz normal mit Speedtest ausprobiert.
Finish.
Okay.
Allow the app to use your location.
No.
Okay.
Ich muss das...
...Allowen.
Missing permissions.
Okay, ich muss dem erlauben, dass der mir anzeigt.
Der muss meinen Standort wissen.
Okay, warum auch immer das wichtig ist.
Okay, allow.
Also, measure WiFi.
Start.
220 Mbit.
Sagt er mir auch.
Okay.
Warum ist das jetzt so viel schneller als das andere?
Was für Magic macht diese Fritz-App?
Okay, 224 Mbit.
Es ist ziemlich...
Es ist ziemlich konstant.
Die Übertragungsrate...
Und der Ping...
...schwang zwischen, ja, 5 Millisekunden, 6 Millisekunden, 7 Millisekunden.
Also, es ist alles ziemlich...
...eats.
Gut.
Die App hätte jetzt wirklich nicht gebraucht.
So, wieder löschen.
Remove.
Let's go.
...Router in einem Metallschaltschrank drin hatten.
Und Metallschränke sind jetzt nicht so optimal, was funktioniert.
Das stimmt.
Generell ist das gut, wenn euer Router...
Ist halt das Ding...
Das ist halt das Ding, was ich euch erzählt habe, vor allem bei meinem ehemaligen Kollege, wo die Frau die Fritzbox nicht sehen möchte und die Kabel nicht sehen möchte.
Und sie deswegen jetzt hinter einer Wand vor einem Schrank am Rande des Hauses steht.
Und sich dann wiederum beschwert wird, dass der WLAN-Empfang so schlecht ist.
Ja, selbst schuld.
Scheidungsgrund.
Zum Beispiel kann er auf einem Schrank liegen.
Ansonsten solltet ihr noch darauf achten, dass bei der gedachten Direktverbindung zwischen...
Soll ich euch mal was dazu sagen?
Ich weiß, dass es ein Witz ist, aber...
Das ist meistens sogar sehr kontraproduktiv, wenn man versucht, sein WLAN irgendwie abzuschirmen.
Das führt meistens nur dazu, dass die Sendeleistung bei den Geräten ein bisschen erhöht wird, damit man noch besseren Empfang bekommt.
Also es kann durchaus sein, dass man es damit sogar verschlechtert.
Also verschlimmert seine Strahlenbelastung, wenn man versucht, die Strahlenbelastung zu verringern.
...euren Geräten und dem Router keine Metallteile, zum Beispiel den Kühlschrank, die verbinden.
Eine coole Sache sind aber Spiegel.
Bei alten WLAN, bei 2,4 GHz WLAN, war Mikrowellen richtig ein Problem, weil die auch auf 2,4 GHz gerauscht haben.
...nämlich Funkwellen tatsächlich um die Ecke herum leiten.
Ähnlich gut funktionieren auch manche Fotos, wenn sie auf Metallplatten angeklebt sind.
Aber alles, was dann hinter dem Spiegel oder der Fotoplatte oder dem Metallschrank steht, das kriegt die Funkwellen natürlich nicht ab.
Funkwellen natürlich nicht ab. Außerdem
wichtig ist die Generation der WLAN-Hardware,
also WiFi 4, 5, 6
oder 7, je höher, desto besser. Aber
da steckt der Teufel natürlich auch im Detail,
siehe unser Video zu WiFi
7. Auf jeden Fall spielt so gefummelt
wie früher mit irgendwelchen Funkkanälen
heute keine wirkliche
Rolle mehr. Der Router verwaltet das
standardmäßig von alleine und das gilt auch
für die genutzten Frequenzbänder, also
2,4. Wie gesagt, meistens muss man
da gar nichts machen, habe ich ja vorhin auch schon gesagt.
5 oder 6
Gigahertz. Ich hatte bei mir früher immer
separate 2,4 und 5 Gigahertz WLAN.
Übrigens, ich wurde gescampt. Zumindest fühle ich mich
ein bisschen gescampt. Ich habe mir
diesen Microcontroller
gekauft für unsere
Zigbee
Bastelgeschichten, ja.
Und da steht eindeutig
Supports WiFi 6.
Was würdet ihr bei diesem
Titel denken, was dieses Gerät
supportet?
2,4 Gigahertz
oder 5 Gigahertz oder 6
Gigahertz oder alles oder nur
2,4 und 5. Also ich habe
gedacht, das Ding supportet
WiFi 6, das heißt
2,4 und 5 Gigahertz WLAN.
Dachte ich mir so, wenn da
WiFi 6 steht, ne?
2,4 und 5. Würdet ihr auch
denken, tja,
falsch gedacht.
Die China-Chinesen unterstützen nur
den WiFi 6 Standard.
Allerdings, sie unterstützen kein
5 Gigahertz WLAN.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das
irgendwie sich ausschließt, ja.
Oder
sich irgendwie, das ist das eine
nicht das andere bedingt. Aber du
brauchst anscheinend, um WiFi 6 draufschreiben
zu können, keine 5 Gigahertz
Unterstützung. Guck hier,
hier steht, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es hier irgendwo drinnen steht.
Äh,
2,4 Gigahertz.
Ja, Bandbreite
WLAN. Unterstützt
du den? Im 2,4 Gigahertz
Band. WiFi-Frequenz
2,4 Gigahertz.
Ich bin, ich bin einfach
blind davon ausgegangen, dass es
der erste ordentliche Microcontroller von
Espressif ist, der 5 Gigahertz
WLAN kann.
Und ZigBee, was mega nice ist. Aber
nein, er kann bloß weiterhin
2,4 Gigahertz.
Ey, ohne Scheiß, Theo, als
liest du dir den ganzen Mist vorher immer im Detail
durch. Vielleicht sind das auch einfach
nur die China-Chinesen, die den Standard
etwas, ähm, offener
interpretiert haben, als er ist. Ich weiß
nicht. Aber das ist ziemlich doof, weil
kein 5 Gigahertz.
Was bringt dann WiFi 6? Korrekt.
So gut wie nix. Vielleicht
so ein paar Optimierungen drumherum, aber
ansonsten eigentlich kein Unterschied.
Da fühle ich mich etwas gescampt.
Allerdings ist das nicht so schlimm.
Bei 9 Euro
für, bei 10 Euro für das Board.
Weil das Board selber ist ja immer
noch sehr nice. Mit ZigBee
und Bluetooth und
dann.
Ja.
Hier steht's doch, genau.
Das ist ja...
Mehr Damage.
Ja, ist ja im Prinzip das, was ich
vorhin auch gesagt hab. Ja, also
man bekommt mehr Range bei 2,4
Gigahertz. Weil 2,4
Gigahertz, also je kleiner
oder, ey, Schwachsinn.
Je größer, ist in dem Fall richtiger.
Je größer die Wellenlänge,
umso
also 2,4 Gigahertz
hat eine größere Wellenlänge, eine
als 5 und 6 Gigahertz.
Umso einfacher
geht das durch Mauern
und Objekte durch.
Deswegen gehen ja so Sachen
wie LoRa beispielsweise
richtig weit.
LoRa hat,
LoRa läuft, glaube ich,
auf 833
Megahertz oder sowas.
Und dazu kommt, dass
die Bandbreite, was da
übertragen wird, auch noch enorm
langsam, ja 868
Megahertz, genau. Dass die
Bandbreite enorm langsam ist.
Also, du hast quasi
eh schon ganz gute
Frequenz, wo du durch Sachen durchkommst.
Dazu kommt, dass die nur
ein paar Bytes verschicken
in
Sekunden, ja.
Also bei LoRa kannst du, wenn du's
auf wirklich maximale Reichweite
trimmen willst, kannst du einstellen,
dass das irgendwie
3 Sekunden sendet für
ja,
einen Int oder so. Oder für ein paar Byte.
Für irgendwie 10 Byte hast du
2 Sekunden Zeit zu senden. Und das
in Kombination mit der,
äh, großen Wellenlänge
und der langen Zeit
für's Senden ist halt die
Reichweite bei LoRa extrem.
Also ich hab's, ich hab's bei mir geschafft,
von mir daheim
mit LoRa,
da hatte ich hier auf dem Schrank,
hatte ich so einen selbstgebauten
LoRa,
ja, kein Gateway, stimmt nicht wirklich, weil der mit
nix verbunden war, liegen.
Und ich hab bei mir
in Rucksack mit einer Powerbank
dran, ein ESP2,
mit LoRa-Board und Antenne
reingepackt. Und ich habe
die Kommunikation hinbekommen
über 1,3
Kilometer Entfernung.
Und das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie
easy gewesen. Hier sind jede Menge
Sachen, Häuser und alles mögliche
im Weg. Aber es
ging. Über 1,3 Kilometer
konntest du kommunizieren.
Mit der Basisstation quasi und meinem LoRa-Endgerät.
Also da sieht man schon, das macht einen Riesenunterschied.
Die Frequenz.
Die Großregel ist, 5 Gigahertz und neuerdings 6 Gigahertz
sind deutlich schneller als 2,4 Gigahertz-Netze,
haben aber auch eine deutlich niedrigere Reichweite als 2,4 Gigahertz-Netze.
Was bringt dann das Abschalten von 2,4 Gigahertz?
Ganz einfach, wenn ihr viele Nachbarn habt, die 2,4 Gigahertz verwenden,
dann ist dieses Band sowieso überbevölkert.
Abschalten kann dann helfen, weil bei 5 und 6 Gigahertz auch die Stör-Reichweite kürzer ist.
Ob es was bringt, muss man dann halt ausprobieren.
Nummer 4, iPerf nutzen.
Da die Fritz-WLAN-App nur auf Smartphones funktioniert,
muss man am Laptop oder Desktop auf eine andere Möglichkeit zugreifen,
wenn man den Datendurchsatz messen will.
Das ist sinnvoll, weil wenn Smartphone und Laptop verschiedene WLAN...
Und lasst euch bei iPerf nicht gebeten, wenn ihr UDP testet,
wegen dem angeblichen Packet-Loss, den das anzeigt.
... an Hardware haben, dann laufen die auch unterschiedlich gut mit demselben Router.
Anstatt Fritz-WLAN nimmt man bei Fritz-Boxen iPerf.
iPerf ist in Fritz-Boxen schon eingebaut.
Ach ja, ist es? Damit können Netzwerkspecken...
...definiert gemessen werden, das benutzen wir bei unseren CT-Tests auch immer.
Also wie schnell ein bestimmtes Notebook, ein NAS, eine virtuelle Maschine oder ein
Raspi an den Router angebunden ist.
Einfach iPerf auf dem Netzwerkgerät installieren und kurz laufen lassen.
Die Fritz-Box antwortet auf iPerf-Requests nur kleinseitig.
Deswegen funktionieren nur iPerf in Version 1 und 2.
Aktivieren könnt ihr den iPerf-Server der Fritz-Box im Support-Menü unter Durchsatzmessung.
Einfach über den Browser aufrufen und hier alle drei Haken setzen.
Je nach Gerät müsst ihr dann noch iPerf 2.x über die üblichen Paketmanager unter
Linux oder Mac installieren.
Da ist schon...
Ich muss jetzt mal was sagen.
Die Fritz-Box.
Ich finde, die ist ein ganz gutes Beispiel für, wie man ein ordentliches Webinterface
bauen kann.
Ich finde das wirklich gut gemacht.
Es ist ziemlich simpel und klar geregelt, obwohl es relativ viele Funktionen darin
unterbringt.
Man findet eigentlich alles recht schnell.
Und es fühlt sich auch halt wie eine normale Webseite an, weniger wie eine App.
Also ich finde das eigentlich ganz gut gemacht.
Und die müssen halt auch mit der Hardware-Limitierung auskommen.
Du merkst dem Webinterface schon an, dass es nicht das schnellste ist.
Aber ansonsten ist es für mich echt ganz gut.
Ja, früher sah das sehr behilfsmäßig aus, aber du merkst, dass AVM da schon seit einer
Weile tatsächlich ein paar ordentliche Webentwickler sitzen hat.
Im Vergleich zu früher.
Früher hatten sie das eher nicht.
Also wohl ein paar, welche die designtechnisch ein bisschen was können, als auch welche,
die alte Webseiten entwickeln können.
Also das ist deutlich besser geworden.
Früher hast du recht.
Früher war das sehr behilfsmäßig.
Benutzt ihr Windows, könnt ihr euch das fertige Binary auf der Entwickler-Webseite
Ja, IPerf unter Windows macht richtig Probleme teilweise.
Einfach runterladen.
Vor der Messung solltet ihr darauf achten, dass eure Firewall den UDP- und TCP-Verkehr
auf Port 4711 und 4712 durchlässt, nachdem ihr
Was macht denn sowas unter Windows, Keckway?
Zum Beispiel.
Nummer 5.
Repeater aufstellen.
Denn wenn das passiert, solltet ihr entweder die Distanz zum Router verkürzen, was ja
wahrscheinlich nicht so einfach ist in den meisten Fällen, weil die Hausanschlüsse ja
irgendwo fest verbaut sind, oder ihr verbessert
Am besten, wisst ihr was das Beste ist?
Zweiter Access Point aufstellen, dort wo man halt noch Kabel hat.
Ja, ich getter, dass das oftmals nicht so easy ist, weil du musst halt erstmal mit dem
Kabel hin.
Aber Kabel ist halt echt einfach Beste und wird auch Beste bleiben.
Die WLAN-Versorgung per zusätzlichen Mesh-Node.
Also einen Repeater aufstellen oder besser noch einen Access Point.
Ein Repeater schnappt sich ein WLAN-Signal und wiederholt es einfach, sodass dasselbe
Datenpaket doppelt gesendet wird.
Dadurch halbiert sich leider die Geschwindigkeit.
Ein Mesh hat mehr Eigenintelligenz.
Das heißt, in einem Mesh-Netzwerk entscheidet der Router und der Mesh-Repeater automatisch,
welches Endgerät sich mit dem Router oder Repeater verbindet, je nachdem, was die bessere
Leistung bringt.
Und wenn ich den Access Point als Mesh-Client per Kabel an den Mesh-Master anstelle...
Ja, was bei...
Was bei Mesh halt auch so ist, da können beispielsweise die Access Points miteinander
reden und besseren Handover oder wie nennt man das bei WLAN?
Also wenn du jetzt beispielsweise mit deinem Handy vom einen Wirkungsbereich von Access
Point A in den Wirkungsbereich zu den Access Point B gehst, dass sie das dann ordentlich
übergeben, sodass du keine Verbindungsabbrüche hast, wenn du den Access Point wechselst.
Wenn du den Access Point wechselst.
Im gleichen WLAN, aber unterschiedliche Access Points.
Hant...
Over?
Oder irgendwie.
Da gibt es irgendein spezielles Wort für.
WLAN ist nicht so meine Spezialität.
... erspart ihr euch auch den doppelten WLAN-Versand.
AVM hat eine Mesh-Funktion in die Fritzboxen integriert.
Da entsteht ein Mesh-System, in dem man einen passenden Repeater oder Access Point dazustellt
und ihn dann mit dem Router koppelt, einfach an beiden Geräten...
Da war jetzt nicht so wirklich Neues dabei, ne?
Also im Prinzip das, was ich auch gesagt habe.
Der Auer!
Das ist jetzt der neueste Trend.
RGB-Mainboards sind out.
Jetzt gibt es RGB plus Farben.
Ja, man muss da...
Man muss...
Aus Prinzip muss man da rein.
Ich hab gedacht, der klettert jetzt noch...
Ah, jetzt, hä?
Der klettert noch komplett rein.
Der traut der Sache noch nicht so richtig.
Also Chico hätte das Ding schon längst runtergeschmissen.
Ach nee, das liegt auf der Erde, gell?
Jetzt aber.
Ah, ah, ah!
Er hat es schon optimiert!
Jetzt!
Haha...
Ach ja...
Aber das gefällt ihm da drin.
Woran das liegt?
Weiß ich vielleicht...
Also...
Ich kann das jetzt auch nur raten.
Ich glaube, die fühlen sich da sicher drin.
Ist ein bisschen...
Es gibt ja auch so...
Für so ganz ängstliche Katzen gibt es ja so...
So...
Das sind so...
Das sind so Kompressionsdinger zum Anziehen.
Da kannst du dir quasi so...
So nen...
So nen Hemd umziehen.
So ein Hemd umziehen, wenn du es so willst.
Und das drückt dann so ein bisschen auf die Katze von außen.
So als wären die irgendwo drinnen und würden festgehalten.
Und da fühlen die sich sicherer.
Das gibt es so für so besonders ängstliche Katzen.
Ja.
Gibt es ein paar.
Was macht eigentlich dein Monitorsetup?
Wieso?
Das ist immer noch das gleiche.
Zwei Stück.
Wie die ganze Zeit.
Nichts.
Nichts Neues.
Ja, ne.
Da hatten wir es gerade am Anfang vom Stream von.
Die Chancen, dass ich mir einen OLED-Monitor hole, werden immer wahrscheinlicher.
Gerade, dass es jetzt welche gibt mit noch ordentlicher Refresh-Rate.
Latency war ja eh schon immer gering.
Aber bis jetzt bleibe ich erstmal bei dem Setup.
Alter, was für Schwachsinn ich empfohlen bekomme.
Ist ja nur Schrott dabei.
Was hältst du eigentlich von Pirate-Software?
Von was?
Also ich denke da jetzt irgendwie an.
Irgendwelche illegalen Downloads, aber kennst du den?
Ne.
Ach, das ist ein Stream-Soar.
Ne, kenne ich nicht.
Alter, 10.000 Viewer.
Nicht schlecht.
Da geht es ja richtig ab.
So, was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Was haben wir denn hier am Start noch?
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Ah, da habe ich Bock.
Die gucke ich mega gerne, die Videos.
Was zur Hölle?
Da gibt es in letzter Zeit wenig welche in der Richtung.
Menschentiere-Automationen oder sowas in der Richtung.
Gucken, was die Leute wieder eingeschickt haben.
Ein Home-Automation-Krempel.
Was zur Hölle?
Nein, Tim?
Einfach nein.
Lügenmedien oder was?
Das ist eine öffentliche Warnung.
Heute schauen wir uns wieder eure Smart-Homes an.
Lassen wir uns inspirieren von euren Pflanzprojekten, Kellern, Treppen, Fenstern und viel mehr.
Das ist schon...
...wieder viel zu lange her.
Wie immer bekommen alle gezeigten Einsendungen von mir einen 50-Euro-Amazon-Gutschein als kleines Dankeschön.
Und wir fangen an mit Sascha.
Und der hat ein HomeKit-Smart-Garden-Projekt hier am Start.
Ich möchte euch heute mein Smart-Garden-Projekt vorstellen.
Das sieht schon mal super erspannt aus.
3D-gedruckt, oder?
Man sieht hier so ein bisschen die...
...glaube ich zumindest, die Bahnen.
Dieses besteht aus einem Wasserbehälter.
Ja, auch alles 3D-gedruckt.
Amazon.
Im Inneren ist ein ESP32.
Ein Füllstands-Sensor und ein Relais, welches verwendet wird...
Warum legst du dich nicht auf die Couch?
...um eine Aquarium-Pumpe anzusteuern.
Außerdem ein paar Gardena-Düsen und einige 3D-gedruckte Teile.
Einsatzfähig ist das Ganze in wenigen Minuten.
Zur Steuerung...
Moment mal, Freundchen.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass diese Pflanze keine Bewässerung braucht.
Lügenmedien oder was?
Dazu setzt man...
Fähig.
...einmalig das WLAN-Passwort.
Und anschließend lässt sich das Smartgarden-Projekt wie jedes HomeKit-Gerät hinzufügen.
Irgendwie habe ich die übelste Abneigung gegen HomeKit.
Ich kann das auch nicht so richtig beschreiben.
Das Einzige, wofür ich plane...
Wow, was ist mit meinem Headset los?
Sekunde.
Das sind jetzt ja...
Ich glaube, ich muss das mal wieder entknoten.
Sekunde.
So, gleich viel besser.
Das Einzige, wofür ich plane, Webkits zu verwenden,
ist, dass ich über CarPlay...
...mein Hoftor aufmachen kann.
Weil CarPlay das Einzige ist in diesem Auto,
wo ich irgendwie Zugriff darüber, über Umwege Zugriff auf mein Home-Automation-System bekommen könnte.
Alternativ, alternativ,
könnte ich auch einfach einen ZigBee-Schalter oder sowas
ins Auto legen.
Nun kann die Bewässerung manuell, per Siri oder per Kurzbefehl gestartet oder gestoppt werden.
Sollte der Wasserstand...
Das ist schon echt ganz schön advanced für drei Blumentöpfe, oder?
...und kann auch nicht mehr gestattet werden, bis das Wasser nachgefüllt wird.
Da sehen wir halt schon wieder eine von diesen Limitierungen von HomeKit.
Also die grundsätzliche Funktion, dass du es nicht wieder anschalten kannst, ist natürlich super.
Aber es ist auch ein bisschen nervig, dass man keine Fehlermeldung geben kann.
Also als Benutzer sehe ich ja nicht...
Was ist deine Lieblings-CI-Plattform, GitHub?
Oder ist der Füllstand zu niedrig?
Also einfach eine Fehlermeldung zurückgeben zu können, wäre schon sehr viel wert.
Unter dem Link in der Videobeschreibung findet ihr eine Übersicht über alle benötigten Bauteile,
unter anderem die 3D-Druckdaten...
Okay, das würde bei meinem Projekt nie passieren, weil das ist ordentlich dokumentiert.
Was ist da los?
Was das für Zeit gekostet hat?
...um herunterladen, einen Anschlussplan, das Homespan-Projekt zum Flaschen des ESPs...
Dokumentation.
...Tipps und Tricks zur Einrichtung.
Ich hoffe, das Projekt hat euch gefallen.
Das hat es, Sascha.
Auf jeden Fall glaube ich auch, dass smartes Gardening sicherlich jetzt so am 1.4. nochmal einen Aufwind erfahren wird.
Und aus völlig anderen Gründen hatte ich mir das in der Vergangenheit auch schon mal angeschaut.
Und da gibt es ja auch jede Menge fertige Lösungen.
Ja, so sehe ich das auch, Theo, oder?
...eingebaut und allem.
Aber vieles davon ist wirklich eher Deko für die Küche.
Wenn du das als Familie benutzt...
Wenn du das als Familie benutzen willst, brauchst du schon ein bisschen mehr als einen einzelnen Salatkopf oder eine Basilikum-Pflanze.
Trotzdem ist das Ganze ein Thema, das ich mir ganz gut vorstellen kann.
Was meinst du?
Ist smartes Indoor-Gärtnern ein Thema für dieses Jahr?
Nee.
Sollte es eins sein?
Nein, soll es nicht.
Daniel hat ein kurzes Video...
Mir geht schon Outdoor-Gärtnern extrem auf den Sack.
...geschickt und hat gesagt, er hat seinen Keller hochmodernisiert.
Schauen wir mal rein in seinen Keller.
Ich bin ein Künstler.
Ich als zukünftiger Kellerbesitzer natürlich sehr interessiert daran bin, was man da noch rausholen kann.
Was macht eigentlich sein Haus?
Das ist quasi mein Lebenswerk, mein Magnum Opus.
Und zwar habe ich hier diesen Schalter im Lichtkeller, um das Licht zu steuern.
Aber das war es noch nicht.
Denn ich vergesse immer wieder, diesen Lichtschalter auszuschalten, wenn ich aus der Tür rausgehe.
Und jetzt habe ich mir was einfallen lassen.
Und zwar habe ich hier über diesen Lichtschalter eine Schnur gespannt.
Diese Schnur geht dann um die Ecke.
Wow.
Und außen dann wieder an die Tür dran.
Und wenn man die Tür zumacht, dann spannt sich diese Schnur und macht den Lichtschalter aus.
Das kann man ja kaum schon Home Automation nennen.
Das ist Oldschool.
Das hätte mein Opa auch bauen können.
Aber man sieht wieder, die Sachen, die nützlich sind, müssen nicht zwangsläufig kompliziert sein.
Und das sind so Sachen, die halt wirklich einen Mehrwert bringen.
Vielen Dank.
Ähm, ja.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich sagen soll.
Sowas sieht man selten.
Ne, aber tatsächlich muss eine Automation ja nicht immer mit Bluetooth und Batterien und Wifi und Programmieren sein.
Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Das ist Single Threaded, korrekt.
Am Ende hast du eine Automation gebaut, die wahrscheinlich zuverlässiger läuft, als die meisten anderen, die wir heute noch sehen werden.
Und von daher kann ich nur sagen, Hut ab!
Und wenn ihr auch noch Fragen habt, dann schreibt sie in die Kommentare.
Wenn ihr auch mechanische oder digitale Automationen gebaut habt, dann werft sie gerne unter zeug.cool.de ein.
Ich laufe langsam trocken.
Dann hat Tim eine Automation automatisiert Garagentor öffnen mit Hilfe eines Switchboards geschickt.
Schauen wir mal rein.
Heute im Video zeige ich euch, wie ihr automatisieren könnt.
Ist das eine AI-Stimme?
Was zur Hölle?
Das machen wir aber nicht.
Nein.
Nein, Tim?
Einfach nein.
Auf geht's, sobald ihr mit dem Auto in die Nähe kommt.
Da ich nur zum Mieten wohne, habe ich meinen altmodischen Toröffner mit einer 3D-getruppten
Haltung und meinem Switchboard kombiniert.
Leider lassen sich nach meinem Wissenstand keine ortsabhängigen Automatisierungen ohne Bestätigung am iPhone umsetzen.
Deswegen nutze ich einen Fokusmodus, welcher ortsbezogen aktiviert werden kann.
Dieser triggert dann einen über IFTT erstellten Hook.
Wie gibt's das noch? Ich dachte, das wurde eingestellt.
IFTT.
Welcher den Switchboard betätigt.
Anschließend geht der Fokusmodus wieder aus.
Eine Anstrengung ist leider, dass kein anderer Status aktiv sein kann, wie zum Beispiel nicht stören.
Wenn dies der Fall ist, funktioniert die Automatisierung nicht.
Also, Punkt 1, das ist eine öffentliche Warnung.
Wer mich in Zukunft hier mit AI-Zuhilfenahme verunglimpft, fliegt einfach raus.
Das wollen wir hier gar nicht einreißen lassen.
Zu der eigentlichen Automation.
Also, Automation mit ortsbasierten...
Wann glaubst du, ist der Homeoffice?
Wie geht der Automatisierungshype um?
Gab es da jemals einen großen Hype?
Ich glaube, das wird einfach kontinuierlich immer weiter ein Thema sein, weil es was ist, was den Leuten auch was bringt.
So einen Hype in Form von, jeder macht es und zwei Monate später interessiert es keinen mehr, gab es ja da nie.
Das hat jetzt kontinuierlich zugenommen die letzten Jahre über.
Ja, es liegt einfach daran, denke ich mal, weil es mehr Leute realisiert haben.
Und weil es auch viel mehr Möglichkeiten und Produkte gibt, die für normale Gehirne umsetzbar sind oder benutzbar sind.
Früher musstest du enorm viel selber bauen.
Da dürftest du dir schon gleich mal überlegen, okay, wie baust du eine eigene Firmware für einen ESP2866 und sagst nur, okay, wie fläche ich das Motor und so.
Da steigen die meisten Leute noch aus, ja.
Mittlerweile kriegst du vieles schon ganz brauchbar auch.
Was sicherlich auch an der immer größeren Verbreitung von ZigBee und wie sieht es eigentlich mit Meta und Threat aus?
Das ist so ein Ding, wo ich mir immer so denke, ist das jetzt der große Durchbruch gewesen oder nicht?
Oder verschwindet das wieder?
Also ich habe immer noch den Eindruck, als ist ZigBee die dominanteste Funktechnologie in der Home, in der Heimautomatisierung.
Vom Ansatz her, vor ein paar Jahren hätte ich gesagt, ist Z-Wave eigentlich viel nicer.
Weil Z-Wave garantiert eben Kompatibilität untereinander.
Das garantiert ZigBee nicht, aber es gibt so viele ZigBee-Hilfstools mittlerweile, dass du auch 99% der ZigBee-Geräte benutzen kannst ohne die offizielle App und ohne irgendwie Zeug vom Hersteller.
Sondern beispielsweise mit ZigBee to MQTT und das ZigBee in Home Assistant ist ja auch ganz gut mittlerweile.
Ja, also ich würde immer noch sagen, trotz...
Also mit Meta und Threat...
Also Meta kannst du ja auch über ZigBee machen oder über WLAN machen, ja.
Ist ZigBee immer noch das vorherrschende Funkprotokoll?
Also wie gesagt, ich sehe da keinen Hype, der irgendwie um ist.
Ich sehe da ein bisschen mehr Interesse bei den Leuten in den letzten Jahren.
Aber einen großen Hype gab es ja da gar nicht.
...Geschichten ist ja irgendwie eine immerwährende Baustelle in HomeKit.
Und war das nicht so, dass nur sicherheitsrelevante Dinge in HomeKit nicht aufgenommen wurden?
Hat HomeKit nicht automatisiert gesteuert werden können, ohne sie zu bestätigen?
Also ich glaube, eine Tür oder ein Garagenturm...
Ja, HomeKit ist immer...
Das klingt so nach typischem Apple-Abfuck.
Mit Automatisierung hat es Apple einfach nicht so.
Sieht man ja auch schon beispielsweise, wenn man sich mal Tasker anguckt.
Versus Shortcuts, du kannst... äh, nicht Shortcuts.
Doch, Siri-Shortcuts heißt es jetzt.
Ich kann mir immer nicht merken, wie das aktuell gerade heißt.
Das ist halt sicherlich das schönere UI, ja.
Aber die Möglichkeiten bei Tasker sind einfach viel, viel umfangreicher.
Was aber auch nicht nur an Tasker liegt, sondern das eben auch Android da viel mehr erlaubt.
Also für Automatisierung ist es not even close, ja.
Eine Steckdose aber nicht.
Und ich habe mich jetzt lange nicht damit auseinandergesetzt, aber damals bei den Alarmanlagen war es dann so,
dass viele als Workaround eine echte oder eine virtuelle Steckdose irgendwo ins Haus gehängt haben.
Die wird aus der Ferne geschaltet und dann gibt es eine Automation.
Sobald die Steckdose eingeschaltet wird, wird dann die Alarmanlage oder in diesem Fall das Garagentor scharf geschaltet bzw. geöffnet.
Ob das funktioniert, weiß ich nicht.
Deins funktioniert.
Also von daher gibt es natürlich keinen Grund, sich damit an deiner Stelle jetzt noch aus einfacher gehen.
Natürlich super simpel zu finden.
Und aufgrund eines Nichts-Durcheinanders ist an dieser Stelle jetzt gerade keine Werbeeinblendung zu finden.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, nutze ich in den Lädträgen von Kanälen,
die dann den Kanalmitglieden zugänglich sind.
So und da schauen wir jetzt auch mal rein.
Moin Andreas.
Moin.
Und ein Gruß an alle Verfechter der Faulheit.
Kein Grund mich doppelt zu grüßen, aber danke.
Neubau einer Lüftungsanlage von Wolf.
Und an der Seite hier ist normalerweise ein Waldschalter, Stufe 1, 2, 3, 4.
Nach dem Duschen drehe ich dann die dann rum.
Wenn ich es mache, läuft die Anlage wieder zwei Tage durch, weil ich ihn vergessen habe.
Das ist Mist.
Deswegen haben wir jetzt hier ein Wemos D1 Mini, auf dem das Motor läuft.
Der schaltet Relais.
Das sieht aus wie die ganz normalen, diese dicken Relais-Boards, die man sich kaufen kann bei Amazon.
Oder irgendwie zwei, drei drauf sind.
Und somit die Stufen durch.
Das geht dann über eine RJ12-Buchse an das...
Oder ist das was von dem Gerät selbst?
Das originale Kabel ist rückrüstbar.
Man erkennt nicht wirklich was, ne?
Und die Luftfeuchtigkeit wird alle zehn Minuten oben gemacht.
Alle zehn Minuten oben gemessen.
Im Bad.
Das ist jetzt der erste Raum.
Bad unten kriegen den Sensor auch noch.
Und die Küche.
Das heißt, egal wo irgendwo die Luftfeuchtigkeit im Haus ansteigt, die Anlage fährt hoch.
So, da haben wir ihn.
Den Mikrocontroller, der Mist.
Wie gesagt, der ist jetzt nur im Bad oben.
Das ist der Prototyp.
Noch kein Gehäuse gedruckt.
Kein nix.
Das kommt aber noch.
Also, das wird nicht lange halten mit der Batterie.
Die Dinger haben keinen...
Ja, eindeutig IP67, das Ding.
Die Dinger haben aber auch keinen sonderlich geringen Sleep-Verbrauch.
Also, das hält nicht lange mit der Batterie.
Es läuft vielleicht eine Woche oder so.
Dann war's das.
Doch, die haben Deep Sleep.
Aber die Standard D1 Mini sind nicht stromsparend im Deep Sleep.
Die brauchen dann irgendwie immer noch 10 Milliampere oder so.
Und das hält halt nicht lang.
Das muss ich erstmal testen, bevor ich hier stundenlang rumkriege.
Das hält vielleicht eine Woche oder zwei.
Dann ist das leer.
Das ist ein Momentverballer.
18650er Batterie.
Eine alte aus einer Dampfe.
Das Board kostet irgendwie 4 Euro bei Aliexpress.
Der Sensor kostet irgendwie 1-2 Euro.
Das ist so ein Bosch BME 280.
Ja, die sind nicht schlecht, die Dinger.
Da habe ich auch ein paar von.
Deep Sleep ist nicht komplett aus.
Ne, ne.
Der arbeitet über 8 Stunden.
Ja, der arbeitet über 8 Stunden.
Du kannst das machen.
Es gibt ESP 2866, die haben davor nochmal so eine extra Schaltung.
Da ist das so.
Aber, ne, es ist nicht komplett aus.
Also du kannst den ja auch nach Intervall aufwecken lassen und so.
Du kannst auch sagen, sleep für 4 Stunden, dann wacht er von alleine auf.
Ne, ne.
Die haben, hier in E1, Mini, Deep Sleep, High Consumption in Deep Sleep.
Ja.
Selbst das ist noch gar nicht mal so wenig.
Guck mal, der normale D1 Mini, der braucht 9 Milliamper im Deep Sleep, damit hält die
Batterie 2 Wochen oder so.
Weil das ist ja 24 7.
Hier kommen wir im Bereich, wo das schon eher möglich ist, da was zu betreiben.
Aber das Board, was ich hier am Start habe für meinen Batteriebetrieb, braucht glaube
ich 15 Microampere im Deep Sleep.
Ja.
Das habe ich hier für meine SIGBEE Tests.
Und das braucht im Deep Sleep nur 16 Microampere.
Und das hält dann schon über ein Jahr.
Oder vielleicht sogar 2 Jahre.
Ich habe das mal so grob überschlagen, ja.
Mit so einem 1200mAh Akku.
Das Ding wacht alle 4 Stunden auf, misst die Temperatur, sendet es per SIGBEE und dann
wird wieder Deep Sleep.
Das hält dann schon so 2 Jahre.
Aber wenn du permanent 9 Milliamper ziehst, das hält nicht lange.
Es gibt doch hier IOT Battery Calculator.
Können wir doch mal eintippen hier.
Also, Execution Time, ja, 24 Stunden so.
Also, okay.
Was ist denn, was hat denn so eine Standard 18650 oder so Batterie?
Was haben die denn, diese 18650 Batterie?
Was haben die denn standardmäßig so?
Kapazität, okay, 2300.
Machen wir einfach mal 2300.
Ja, keine Ahnung, 15.
So.
Duration of Code Execution ist egal.
Wir machen hier einfach mal jetzt irgendwie, ja, Sleep Time halt den ganzen Tag so.
One day, two seconds.
Okay.
Ah, Moment, es ist die Sleep Time.
Duration of Code Execution.
Das müssen wir schreiben.
Ein Tag läuft das Ding und braucht, sagen wir mal, dann, ja, 9 Mikroampere.
Ach, jetzt kann das das Ding nicht anzeigen oder was?
Okay, Sleep Time 0.
Ja.
Hält, hält eineinhalb Wochen.
Das geht, das geht schnell, ja.
Man glaubt das gar nicht.
Aber auch Kleinvieh macht Mist bei Standby.
Also, das hält bei dem ein bisschen über eine Woche, sein Konstrukt, was er da gebaut hat.
Wahrscheinlich zieht das auch noch ein bisschen mehr.
Da ist ja noch ein bisschen mehr dran.
Also, es ist ein Riesenunterschied, ob dein Board 9 Milliampere verbraucht oder 16 Mikroampere.
Ja, also, wenn man das mal mit meinem, wenn man das jetzt mal mit meinem Board vergleicht, realistisch gesehen.
Also, ich hab, sagen wir mal, sind wir mal, sind wir mal so, so, so, so nett.
20, 20 Mikroampere.
So, und wir haben, das Ding braucht zwei Sekunden.
Läuft das?
Da braucht es 150 Milliampere.
Und ansonsten Sleep Time, so, das, das, das, das, das sleept immer.
Conversion Wizard, genau.
Das sleept immer 14.000 Sekunden.
So.
Und, aber ich hab nur 1200 Milliampere Stunden Batterie.
Okay, das hält drei Jahre.
Das stimmt aber, realistisch betrachtet, nicht so ganz.
Sagen wir mal, hier, sagen wir mal, vier Sekunden sind wir mal so, machen wir mal so was.
Also, ungefähr zwei Jahre hält meine Konstruktion dann an der Batterie.
Oder halt am Akku.
Also, es ist schon ein Unterschied, ob 9 Mikroampere oder, oder 20 Mikroampere versus 9 Milliampere.
Ich hab eine 0 zu viel?
Nee, warum?
Wo hab ich eine 0 zu viel?
Ich hab keine 0 zu viel.
Also, das macht schon einen Unterschied.
So, weiter geht's.
I2C.
Mhm.
Und, ja, das Ding geht regelmäßig in Deep Sleep, sendet alle 10 Minuten die Daten.
Ich hab das erst mit den Dingern probiert, über Zigbee.
Ich dachte früher, es heißt I2C.
Aber mittlerweile bin ich auch schlauer, weil es I2C heißt.
Aber man schreibt es I2C.
Naja, auch funktioniert ohne Tuya-Gate nicht so toll.
Hm.
Aber, die Lüftungsanlage ist smart.
Und sobald ich dusche, und das ist hier alles klatschnass, regelt der Kollege.
Ja.
Dann muss ich nicht Zukunfts-Stefan dort rumkommen.
Okay, das ist, das ist relativ easy, ja.
Also, finde ich, ist auch eine sinnvolle Automatisierung, die, sagen wir mal, vielleicht ein bisschen
advancer ist, als das, was man mit Fertiggeräten machen kann, aber immer noch ziemlich übersichtlich.
Man misst oben die Luftfeuchtigkeit.
Und im Keller schaltet man seine Lüftung per Relay an und aus.
Macht, macht durchaus Sinn.
Einzige, wo ich echt meine Bedenken hätte, ist das Ding.
Das hält nicht lang.
Wie gesagt, eins bis zwei Wochen, dann ist die Batterie leer.
Der Akku leer.
Also, damit wird er wahrscheinlich nicht so glücklich.
Mit einer Powerbank könnte man das Ganze noch extenden, dann irgendwie auf, keine Ahnung, einen Monat oder so.
Aber das macht ja keinen Sinn.
Also, ich finde, wenn, wenn man
irgendwas Batteriebetriebenes nimmt, dann muss es auch
Low Power sein.
Das Problem ist allerdings,
Deep Sleep
und den Sensor benutzen
ist halt auch so ein Ding,
der will ja nicht, dass es vier Stunden später erst auf seine Luftfeuchtigkeit reagiert,
sondern möglichst schnell.
Da muss der entweder den Ultra Low Power Prozessor benutzen, vom ESP32, der ist relativ stromsparend,
aber nicht so stromsparend.
Also, das ist was, wo ich mir nicht vorstellen kann, dass man das dauerhaft,
ähm, im Akkubetrieb laufen lassen kann.
Da muss man sich irgendwas überlegen.
An dem Schalter zu drehen.
Ansonsten eine super Geschichte.
Von allein.
So soll das sein.
Sowas hätte ich mir auch gebaut.
Müsste ich eine Lüftung im Bad einschalten.
Das ist ja tatsächlich wirkliches Fair Smart Home.
Ja, ist es.
Sonst würde ich sagen, machen wir da jetzt eins draus.
Ist dann die gegebenenfalls hohe Luftfeuchtigkeit auch so eine offene Batterie im Microcontroller nicht auch...
Also,
ja, kann.
Aber,
sagen wir mal so, solange da sich nicht irgendwie Wassertröpfchen dran bildet.
Also,
ehrlich gesagt,
ich würde es nicht offen ins Bad legen bei mir.
Ich glaube nicht, dass was passiert.
Ich habe bei mir im Bad auch einen ESP32 hängen.
Der macht Bluetooth Empfang,
beispielsweise von der Waage.
Das ist so eine Waage, die über Bluetooth geht.
Die sendet das, sendet das dann,
dass ich mein Pippo Fett Time besser tracken kann.
Die habe ich in so einer Box drin,
in so einer Verteilerbox.
So eine billige 80 Cent Box.
Elektroverteilerbox.
Ne, ne, ne.
So was ganz, ganz kleines, billiges.
Ja, sowas hier.
Ein bisschen sowas wie das vordere.
Ein bisschen sowas wie dem vorderen.
Sitzt das...
Sitzt das drinne...
Weiß nicht, was die Box hat.
IP56 oder sowas.
Ein bisschen in so einer Box wie hier da vorne steckt das drinne.
Da ist mir es einfach wohler dabei,
wenn das Ding im Bad hängt.
Ich persönlich denke nicht,
dass ihm da was passieren wird, wenn das...
Also ich meine, im schlimmsten Fall geht halt das Ding kaputt.
Genau so sollte es ja sein.
Okay, im allerschlimmsten Fall fängt der Akku an zu brennen.
Aber das ist sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Du hast eine Anlage und du hast vom Neubau gesprochen.
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen schade,
dass das irgendwie der Stand der Technik offenbar bei den Lüftungsanlagen ist.
Aber jetzt funktioniert es ja.
Und das, was du gebaut hast...
Ich finde, das ist eine gute Automatisierung, die Radar gebaut hat.
Sah jetzt ein bisschen unfancy und ein bisschen schlecht belichtet im Keller aus,
sodass man das gar nicht gesehen hat.
Aber das ist tatsächlich so Quality of Life.
Was man mit Smart Home rausholen kann.
So was.
Und nicht das, womit viele Leute anfangen,
sinnloserweise überall dimmbare RGB-LED-Lampen hin,
die man nicht braucht.
Bei uns ist es so, dass wir ja die Gira Tastsensor 4,
Tastsensorin 4, wie auch immer,
in die einzelnen Zimmer bekommen.
Der hat immer direkt einen Temperatur- und Luftfeuchtesensor verbaut.
Und dann wollen wir davon abhängig eben unsere Lüftung steuern.
So gesehen eigentlich genau das, was du dir gebaut hast.
Sehr cool.
Und die Sensoren selber zu basteln ist natürlich auch ein ganz schönes Projekt.
So, Patricks Klingelautomation.
Was war nochmal die verknüpfte Funktion?
Ich weiß nicht, was du meinst.
Okay.
So, Patricks Klingelautomation.
Ah, ein Acara Vibrationssensor.
Auch eine gute Idee.
Also ich greife bei mir ab, ob es klingelt.
Direkt an dem Draht von der Türgegensprechanlage.
Da ist ein Analog-zu-Digital-Konverter dran,
der feststellt, wenn sich die Spannung darauf ändert.
Gibt so eine ganz komische Spezifikation von meiner Türgegensprechanlage.
Irgendwie, ich glaube, 20 Volt liegen da normalerweise auf der Leitung an.
23, wenn es geklingelt hat.
15, wenn gerade gesprochen wird.
Und dann geht es wieder auf 20.
Total weirdchampiges Analog-Zeug.
Ich habe da einen Analog-zu-Digital-Konverter.
Und sobald sich das Spannungslevel da ändert drauf.
Irgendwie von 20 auf 23 oder so.
Ich glaube, das war es.
Ich weiß es aus dem Kopf gar nicht mehr.
Dann bekommt er das mit.
Und dann bekommt es mein Home Assistant dadurch mit.
Ach so.
Ja, der hat zu hohe Luftfeuchtigkeit im Bad.
Und dafür hat er halt so eine Luftbelüftungsanlage.
Und er misst jetzt, wie hoch die Luftfeuchtigkeit im Bad ist.
Dann geht das über irgendeine Smart Home Lösung.
Oder vielleicht kommunizieren die Sensoren auch direkt miteinander.
Das hat man glaube ich nicht gesehen.
Und unten im Keller hängt auch ein Microcontroller, der einen Relay triggert.
Was seine Lüftung einschaltet.
So dass es keine...
Wahrscheinlich, dass es keinen Schimmel im Bad gibt auf lange Sicht.
Ja.
Simpel, aber sinnvoll.
Vibrationssensor, Klingel checken lassen.
Ja.
Das Problem ist, Vibrationssensoren sind problematisch.
Habe ich auch ein bisschen mit rum experimentiert.
Aber die können öfters mal Fehlalarme auslösen.
Das ist auch sehr gut.
Wir hatten sowas ja schon mal mit...
Das ist der Klingelton.
Das ist eine Klinge, die per Magnet ausgelöst wurde.
Und da dann eben mit einem Fensterkontakt.
Aber ich finde den Vibrationssensor...
Äh...
Aber ich verstehe nicht, warum es nicht auch ein normaler Lüfter tut.
Der hat von außen die Sensoren verbaut.
Wie ein normaler Lüfter.
Der hat ja wahrscheinlich einfach in seinem Haus diese Anlage schon drin.
Was soll denn dann ein normaler Lüfter machen?
Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
Der hat in der...
So wie es für mich auch...
Der hat in der Decke halt so ein Lüftungsding, wo ein Lüfter dahinter ist.
Das ist halt fest verbaut im Haus.
Vielleicht hat er auch gar kein Fenster im Bad oder so.
Und das Ding kann man anscheinend nur zentral einschalten.
Und das Einschalten macht er eben über so ein Relay im Keller.
Vibrationssensor an einer Klingel, die wirklich einen Gong anschlägt.
Auch eine super Idee.
Ja, finde ich auch.
Und ich verlinke euch mal die ganzen Ursprungsvideos...
Ich habe so gut wie alles an Sensoren durch.
Und für Klingel gibt es noch eine weitere Variante.
Wenn ihr eine Klingel habt, die nicht vibriert.
Beim Klingeln, wo es einfach nur einen Ton gibt.
Beispielsweise eine Tür-Gegensprechanlage, wo es dann macht...
Oder sowas.
Da gibt es auch Sensoren, die haben...
Lautstärkesensoren könnte man das nennen.
Im Prinzip ist da ein kleines Mikrofon drin.
Und die können quasi registrieren, wenn nah dran halt hohe Lautstärke ist.
Das geht auch.
Diese Vibrationsdinger, die Lautstärkesensoren und sowas.
Die sind alle immer ein bisschen anfällig für Fehlalarme, wenn was ist.
Wenn du bei so einem Vibrationssensor zu sehr drum herum trampelst, dann hast du vielleicht Probleme.
Wenn du rumschreist, neben deiner Klingel, dann das vielleicht auch.
Also am besten ist tatsächlich, man geht immer direkt an die Signalquelle dran.
Wenn das möglich ist.
So wie ich beispielsweise mit dem Analogs- und Digitalkonverter von meiner Tür-Gegensprechanlage.
Aber wenn das nicht möglich ist.
Oder wenn man beispielsweise zur Miete wohnt und da nicht dran rumschrauben möchte.
Kann das schon sinnvoll sein.
Es gibt glücklicherweise Sensoren für nahezu alles.
Also wirklich. Für nahezu alles.
Eines meiner Lieblingssensoren sind Ultraschallsensoren.
Zur Abstandserkennung.
Ich hatte zum Beispiel mal einen Ultraschallsensor bei mir vor's Kellerfenster gehängt.
Um zu checken, ob der Parkplatz vorm Haus frei ist.
Also Ultraschallsensoren ist MVP-Sensor.
Da kannst du den Abstand messen zu Objekten davor.
Und da habe ich dann eine Nachricht gekriegt.
Parkplatz vorm Haus ist frei.
Wenn einer weggefahren ist.
Weil ich halt permanent den Abstand vom Ultraschallsensor festgestellt habe.
Habe ich jetzt nicht mehr am Start.
Habe ich wieder weggemacht.
Weil im Elektroauto und so.
Ich fahre einfach bei mir in den Hof.
Muss ich eh ab und zu aufladen.
Die Ladestation hängt im Hof.
Also.
Ich parke eigentlich gar nicht mehr auf der Straße.
Weiter.
Einen Sender unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Weil hier auch noch ein bisschen Erklärung zur Einrichtung dabei ist.
Aber auch hier eine alte Lösung.
Mit verhältnismäßig wenig Aufwand.
Smart gemacht.
Schickt jetzt Nachrichten aufs Handy und auf die Homepods.
Fantastisch.
16 Euro Einsatz oder so.
Und schon hat man eine smarte Klingel.
Und einen 50 Euro Amazon Gutschein.
Verlinke ich euch auch.
Die findet ihr unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Julian hat ein Video geschickt.
Das heißt Windows Solar Automation.
Julian.
Ich würde sagen wir gucken mal.
Ach so.
Ich glaube er meint echte Fenster oder?
Also ich habe hier so einen ETH Motion Sensor.
Den neuen mit Thread.
Und der hat ja auch einen Lux Sensor.
Und dann habe ich das so programmiert.
Also einen Helligkeitssensor.
Ja.
Wollte auch gerade sagen.
Immer wenn hier sozusagen.
Ich glaube aktuell habe ich 1000 oder 2000 Lux eingestellt.
Das dann meine Dose angeht.
Und diese Steckdose hier.
MyStrom.
Macht den Inverter dann an.
Hier kann man sehen.
Okay.
80 Watt von zwei Modulen.
Vielleicht nicht so viel.
Aber das sind auch so billige.
Und die sind hier.
Auf der Scheibe.
Einfach so mit Saugnöpfen montiert.
So sieht dann der Ertrag aus.
Für Windows.
Ganz okay.
Ist ja geschenkter Strom.
Der ETH Motion.
Naja.
Gut.
Geschenkt in Form von.
Du hast erstmal ein bisschen Kohle aus.
Gegeben.
Dass du es.
Dass du es überhaupt benutzen kannst.
Zeichnet gerade 3000 Lux.
Also ich habe absichtlich den nicht in die Sonne gestellt.
Der steht im Schatten.
Warum stehen die alle so auf diese Homekit.
Auf diesen Homekit Shit.
Und die Streustrahlung auch.
Sozusagen.
Strom liefern kann.
Er auch ausschlägt.
Wenn es gleich oder.
Unter 1000 als Luxus.
Geht das Ganze aus.
Und wenn es.
Über.
Oder gleich 2000 Luxus.
Geht es an.
Einfach.
Dass da so ein bisschen Spielraum.
Gibt.
Und dann.
weil einfach Preis-Leistung lohnt sich da nicht.
Plus, dass du kaum Handwerker findest, die es machen.
Also die ganze Planung, die Kosten,
den Aufwand zum Montieren, bis du da mal einen hast.
Und dann, dass es, wenn überhaupt, nur sehr langfristig lohnt.
Wobei ich es gar nicht mal primär nur für
es rechnet sich irgendwann machen würde.
Aber es rechnet sich einfach unsinnig aktuell.
Die Lage vom Dach ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich habe das schon ein paar Mal analysiert mit so einem,
da gibt es solche Sonneneinstrahlungs-Maps, wo man gucken kann.
Kann man auch ungefähr hochrechnen lassen,
welche Größe auf welchem Dach und so, was da am meisten bringt.
Ja, das wird es in nächster Zeit bei mir nicht geben.
Auch wenn ich richtig Bock drauf hätte,
gerade was die ganze Technik drumherum angeht.
Der Wechselrichter ja sonst die ganze Zeit mit Netzstrom betrieben werden würde.
Und wenn er dann gleichzeitig nicht produziert,
dann frisst er natürlich, gerade wenn es jetzt nicht so super effiziente Panels sind,
den produzierten Strom auch schnell wieder auf.
Also von daher finde ich ganz gut.
Und die Idee, den Helligkeitssensor von einem Bewegungsmelder zu nehmen,
ist eine Sache, die ich so auch noch nicht gesehen habe.
Finde ich ganz gut.
Christian hat Automation Precon geschickt.
Ja.
Amazon, MonkaS.
Dein EQB 350 4 Matic ist zu Hause und wird nun vorklimatisiert.
Auch ganz spannend.
Also erstmal würde ich deinem Auto einen Spitznamen geben, dann...
Hä? Das habe ich nicht kapiert.
Was?
Ach so, der kann die Klimaanlage vom Auto triggern mit einem Knopf.
Ja. Und? Kann ich auch.
Der Fiat Champ kann das von Anfang an.
Gibt es da eigentlich neue GitHub-Issues?
Weil bisher gibt es ja keine.
Oh.
Nee. Gibt immer noch keine.
Auch ganz spannend.
Also erstmal würde ich deinem Auto einen Spitznamen geben,
dann musst du dir nicht jedes Mal die komplette Typenbezeichnung anhören.
Aber das zur Vorkonditionierung auf so einem Taster, den man...
Ja, das ist aber tatsächlich sehr simpel.
...eine smarte Abendroutine mit Bettsensoren.
Und ich sehe eine Katze, das ist ein Tier, das zählt.
Der Name dieses Formates ist damit erfüllt.
Ähm, los geht's. Wir schauen uns eine smarte Abendroutine mit Bettsensoren an.
Ich möchte euch meine kleine Abend-Bettzeit-Automation in meinem Smart Home vorstellen.
Wenn meine Freundin und ich abends schlafen wollen, können wir entweder per Sprachbefehl
oder automatisiert eine Bettzeit-Automatisierung ausführen,
die die passende Beleuchtung einschaltet und mit einer Zeitverzögerung...
Wisst ihr, was auch sinnvoll wäre?
Einfach dort einen Knopf hinmachen, da drückst du drauf, wenn du ins Bett gehst
und dann schaltet es das ein.
Okay.
Da musst du dir nicht schon um neun überlegen,
ob du heute um zehn oder um halb elf ins Bett gehst.
...bestimmte Geräte in der Wohnung ausschaltet.
Mhm.
Automatisiert wird das Ganze, wenn man sich abends nach 21 Uhr ins Bett legt.
Ah.
Da soll sein können, dass nur eine von uns beiden ins Bett geht.
Ah, hat der einen Drucksensor im Bett?
Wird vorher geprüft, ob der Fernseher im Wohnzimmer
und mein Computer im Arbeitszimmer ausgeschaltet sind.
Dies funktioniert deswegen so gut,
dass wir abends vor dem Schlafengehen entweder zocken oder Fernsehen gucken.
So ist sichergestellt, dass wenn einer ins Bett möchte,
der andere aber noch nicht,
der andere dann auch nicht plötzlich im Dunkeln sitzt.
Das wäre ja irgendwie doof.
Umgesetzt habe ich das Ganze mithilfe von zwei Acara-Wassersensoren
und zusätzlichen Autositzsensoren.
Wozu ein Wassersensor?
Ah, ich weiß! Ich weiß, wozu!
Pfeifert, der benutzt die Kontakte mit was anderem.
Ich wette mit euch, der benutzt die Kontakte nicht.
Also, diese, mal gucken, ob ich recht habe.
Diese, ähm, das ist ja so, Überflutungssensor, ja.
Die haben unten zwei Metallkontakte.
Und normalerweise funktioniert das so,
diese Dinger sind total simpel aufgebaut.
Super, super, hast du.
Die haben unten zwei Metallkontakte.
Und wenn die, ja, so zum Beispiel,
ja.
Und das sieht eigentlich ein bisschen anders aus, ja.
So, und wenn die Kontakte eben
leiten, wenn irgendwas leitet von einem zum anderen Kontakt,
also quasi, wenn die in der Pfütze stehen,
was die ja letztendlich auch detekten sollen,
dann löst das aus.
Du kannst hier unten natürlich beliebige Sachen dranstecken
und das so wie eine Art Schalter, oder nee,
also Detektor verwenden, so.
Ja, mal gucken, ob ich recht habe, was der damit vorhat.
...Soren, die ich einfach bei Amazon bestellt habe.
Die kann man dann super einfach miteinander verbinden.
Und sobald der Sitzsensor durch eine liegende Person ausgelöst wird...
Okay, das ist ein, ein Druck, Drucksensor.
Wenn, warum schaltet denn das so oft an und aus?
...wird der Stromkreis des Wassersensors geschlossen
und der neue Status an Home Assistant gesendet.
Meistens sind wir dann noch eine Weile wach
und gucken irgendeine Serie oder sind am Handy.
Und wenn wir dann richtig schlafen wollen, lässt sich per Sprachbefehl
die Gute-Nacht-Automatisierung triggern,
die dann ebenfalls alles im Schlafzimmer ausschaltet.
Neben dem Sprachbefehl wird das Ganze auch durch Auflegen...
Jetzt, Chat, ich habe es immer noch nicht kapiert,
was ist jetzt mit dem Wassersensor?
Für was war der jetzt gebraucht?
...eine Serie oder sind am Handy.
Und wenn wir dann richtig schlafen wollen,
lässt sich per Sprachbefehl die Gute-Nacht-Automatisierung...
Ach, da ist die Druckplatte dran, okay.
...triggern.
Die dann ebenfalls alles im Schlafzimmer ausschaltet.
Ja, dann stimmt das doch, was ich gesagt habe.
...abschaltet.
Neben dem Sprachbefehl wird das...
Man kann die, man kann diese Sensoren super zweckgleichen.
...nicht an Fremden.
...das Ganze auch durch Auflegen meines Handys
auf das kabellose Ladegerät ausgelöst,
da ich mein Handy jede Nacht darüber auflade.
Im Großen und Ganzen ist das eine sehr angenehme
und trotzdem sehr günstige Automatisierung,
da das meiste einfach im Hintergrund durch Home Assistant verarbeitet wird
und man sich solche Bett-Sensoren für unter 25...
Ich habe mir das auch mal überlegt,
ja,
ob ich das nicht noch gescheit bauen soll bei mir.
Habe ich aber nicht.
Also habe ich nicht im Einsatz jetzt.
Ich hatte mir auch überlegt,
man könnte dann beispielsweise sicherstellen,
dass das Licht aus ist.
Und der Fernseher, falls der mal an oder aus ist und so.
Aber hat sich jetzt nicht so sinnig rausgestellt.
Und irgendwelches gedimmtes Licht
oder irgendeinen so einen
Bettgemodus brauche ich ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Mein Bettgemodus sieht
im Prinzip ganz simpel aus.
Ich gehe ins Schlafzimmer,
schmeiße mein Handy irgendwie nebendran
und mache das Licht aus
und gehe ins Bett.
So.
Da gibt es nicht,
da gibt es nicht so viel zu automatisieren.
Wenn man sich Euro ganz einfach selber zusammenbauen kann.
Ich muss ja sagen,
ich spiele auch mit dem Gedanken,
sowas in der Art zu bauen.
Und tatsächlich liegen hier die
die Withings Sleep Analyzer schon rum.
Also das ist ja im Prinzip das,
was du hier gebaut hast.
Einfach fertig zu kaufen
und mit ein bisschen Schlaf
und Vitalüberwachung.
Allerdings haben wir aktuell das Problem,
dass wir zu selten zu zweit im Bett aufwachen.
Um nicht zu sagen nie.
Und da habe ich ein bisschen Sorge,
dass das alles sowieso durcheinander kommt.
Eure Automation ist natürlich
schon sehr individuell
auf eure Lebensweise abgestimmt.
Ja klar.
Das ist ja auch das, was ich oft sage.
Heimautomatisierung ist
sehr individuell,
was dort einem das Leben erleichtert
und was halt auch nichts bringt.
Deswegen finde ich es immer so blöd,
wenn die Leute anfangen gleich mit Lichtern
und sowas.
Die meisten Lichter,
also die meisten Lichter
machen überhaupt keinen Sinn,
dort irgendwelche RGB oder dimmbare LEDs
hin zu pflanzen.
Generell RGB LEDs
oder RGB Lampen
sind am meisten overrated
overratesten
wenn ich so ein gescheites Wort
aussprechen könne.
Heimautomatisierungs Gadgets ever.
Macht nur an ganz wenigen Stellen
Sinn.
Die meisten Leute,
denen wird es sogar reichen,
wenn man die einfach remote ein- und ausschalten kann.
Und danach vielleicht,
vielleicht dimmbar.
Die nächste Steigung ist Farbtemperatur anpassbar
und danach RGB.
RGB LEDs,
die sind halt auch ziemlich teuer.
Deswegen bei den meisten
reicht das remote ein- und ausschaltbar
und da ist es vielleicht oftmals auch sinnvoller
gar nicht die Lampe so sehr smart zu machen,
sondern vielleicht den Schalter
mit sowas wie beispielsweise
so einem kleinen Shelly oder sowas.
Da kann man nämlich per Smart Home
die Lampe ein- und ausschalten
plus
der Schalter an der Wand
geht auch immer noch.
Das wird nämlich auch oftmals übersehen,
wenn man ganz eifrig rumbaut,
mit RGB Beleuchtung und Heimautomatisierung,
dass die ganzen
Wlan, Wifi oder die ganzen
Smart Lampen
ja alle nur smart sind,
solange sie Strom haben.
Und oftmals drückt man halt trotzdem einfach
den Lichtschalter
und sobald man den Lichtschalter ausschaltet
sind die Dinger auch nicht mehr smart.
Deswegen ist so eine
Automatisierung beispielsweise mit einem Shelly,
dass man eben mit dem Lichtschalter
nicht mehr die Lampe schaltet,
sondern mit dem Shelly
und der Shelly schaltet die Lampe.
Oftmals sinniger, weil dann geht's
Home Automatisierung über Home Assistant Apps
und sonst wie zu schalten
und der Schalter an der Wand geht nach wie vor.
...geprüft wird, ob dann doch noch das Handy an ist
oder so.
Finde ich schon ganz spannend,
damit was zu machen.
Und dann haben wir Lukas,
der hat eine Treppenbeleuchtung
Smart Bewegungserkennung.
Auch das ist eine Baustelle,
die sich bei mir
auch bald auftut.
Von daher
schaue ich mit gespitzten
Ohren und Augen
oder so.
Oben und unten ist jeweils eine Elektronikdose,
also eine etwas größere Unterputzdose.
Boah, schöner Effekt.
Wahrscheinlich komplett unsinnig,
aber sehr schöner Effekt.
Das ist auf jeden Fall
ein Strip mit einer sehr hohen
LED-Dichte
und einem schönen Diffusor.
Darum herum.
Ich komme da mit 24 Volt oben
sowie unten an aus der Unterverteilung.
Da mache ich dann mit einem Spannungswandler
5 Volt raus.
Für den Microcontroller gehe ich dann auf
einen RGB Waste Vibe,
das ist ein SK6812
wo sich jede LED einzeln
triggern lässt oder anschauen lässt.
Das Aluprofil ist Unterputz.
Wurde vor dem Putzer
an der Wand befestigt und dann
kam der Putzer und hat ihn...
Sehr schöner Effekt, finde ich.
Sehr enorm hübsch.
Irgendwie useless.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, als
bräuchte man das, weil man sonst die Treppe runterfällt
oder so.
Aber sehr schicker Effekt.
Hergeputzt.
Als Bewegungsmelder habe ich ganz einfache
günstige Bewegungsmelder
von diesen Arduinos usw.
verwendet.
Die habe ich in eine Blindabdeckung eingeklebt
und als Steuerung habe ich...
Eine Blindabdeckung.
Ich spüre da, oder ich höre
da raus, dass der irgendwas
mit Elektronik macht, weil
niemand weiß, dass das Ding Blindabdeckung heißt.
Ein NodeMCU
verwendet.
Ein ESP32, wo WLED
drauf geflasht wurde, mit einem eigenen
WLED Waste.
Und jetzt kann ich darüber die Angezeit,
Ausgezeit an Bleibzeit einstellen
und die Effekte sowie die Helligkeit.
Und ja...
Optisch sehr schick.
Kommt mit der Kamera
LEDs mit Handyfilm
und so.
Gibt meistens gar nicht den richtigen Eindruck.
Enorm hübsch.
Wenn auch gleichzeitig
überflüssig as fuck.
Aber sehr hübsch.
Das ist eine Sache, die bei mir auch ansteht.
Also wir werden auch eine Beleuchtung
an der Treppe haben.
Allerdings im Handlauf.
Aber das ist ja jetzt erstmal egal.
Aktuell ist nicht vorgesehen, dass sie einzeln adressierbar ist.
Das ist eine Sache,
die mich damals dazu gebracht hat,
zu sagen, ich muss auch für dieses Haus,
das wir sanieren,
einen Instagram Account machen.
Weil ich das bei anderen Leuten gesehen habe,
die mit viel Mühe so ein Haus schick machen
und dann oben und unten
irgendwie einen Taster haben,
um so einen Leuchtstreifen an- und auszuschalten.
Also anzuschalten, wenn man die Treppe runter geht
und auszuschalten, wenn man unten angekommen ist
oder andersrum.
Und das geht nicht.
Das sind Sachen, die ich dann auf jeden Fall
zeigen möchte.
Das muss automatisch sein, das sehe ich auch so.
Damit man nicht mit viel Aufwand ein Haus saniert.
Das sehe ich auch so.
Alles, was du manuell machen musst
und dich nervt, ist ein guter
Aufhänger für Heimautomatisierung.
Meine allererste
Smart Home
Automatisierung war
eine RGB
Lampenanzeige,
wie viel Verspätung die Bahn hat.
Kein Witz,
das war das allererste, was ich gemacht habe.
Als ich noch regelmäßig nach Frankfurt
gefahren bin.
Jetzt ist es ja dank hohem Homeoffice-Anteil
nicht mehr ganz so relevant.
Aber damals war das sehr relevant
für mich und
sobald die Bahn Verspätung hatte,
ging das Ding dann auf Orange
und dann auf Rot
und normal war es auf Grün.
Da habe ich schon direkt morgens,
wenn ich aus dem Bett gekommen bin und aufgestanden bin,
gesehen, aha,
noch bevor ich in die App geguckt habe,
aha, Bahn verkackt es wieder.
Ja, war schon öfters Rot,
ja.
Ich finde auch sehr schön, was du gemacht hast.
Ich finde das mit dem adressierbaren
LED-Streifen.
Leider ist halt die Aktualisierung
in der Bahn-App so für'n Arsch, ja.
Es hat oftmals Grün angezeigt
bis drei Minuten, bevor die
abgefahren ist und dann
ist auf Rot gewechselt, weil ihnen eingefallen ist,
ach nee, da steht ja noch drei Haltestellen vorher.
Das ist dann auch so ein Ding,
wo ich nicht verstehe, wie das überhaupt möglich
ist bei der Bahn. Die müssen doch wissen, wo ihre
Züge sind, sonst wird's doch permanent crashen.
Lohnt sich da ne grüne, naja, wenn es
ne RGB-Lampe ist, hast du halt standardmäßig
alle möglichen Farben dabei.
Der hätte wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich hätte ne Rote
gereicht, ja. Rote aus
heißt alles okay, rote an
heißt Verspätung. Hätte wahrscheinlich auch so'n
Binary State gereicht.
Der hätte so nicht mal rot sein müssen, sondern ganz
normal.
Ja, aber so ist es halt.
Habe ich aber auch nicht mehr am Start.
Den CCC-Vortrag zur Bahn-App,
meinst den, der Bahnexpert
programmiert hat,
ursprünglich hieß dieses seit Jahr
Marudor oder so. Ja, den kenn ich,
den kenn ich. Der ist aber schon ein paar Jahre alt.
Ist natürlich auch ganz spannend. Muss man natürlich
ein bisschen vorsichtig sein, wie wild die
Effekte werden.
Vielen Dank auf jeden Fall an alle
Einsender, vielen Dank an
alle Zuschauer. Musste man nicht
heutzutage sagen, Einsende,
Einsendende.
Und wenn ihr auch was habt, was
ihr in der nächsten Folge sehen wollt,
dann schickt es an zeug.cool
slash zeigen. Und wie gesagt, für jede
gezeigte Einsendung gibt es
einen 50-Euro-Gutschein.
Und dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten Mal.
Oh.
Leute, ich hab
Hunger.
Keine Homelapse-Sachen jetzt.
Da bin ich immer ewig am Erzählen.
Ja. Ja, das ist das
Coole bei der Seite, weil der alle möglichen
APIs anzapft. Ja, da zapft nicht nur die
Bahn-AP an, da zapft bei uns dann auch
BV, Bayerische Dingsbums, Bahn,
HAL, B, alles an. Und da
kannst du dann, ja, das miteinander
vergleichen und zeigst halt einfach das an mit der
größten Verspätung.
Das ist wirklich, also das kann ich nur
empfehlen. Beste Seite,
um Verspätungen bei der Bahn
festzustellen.
Weil, wie gesagt,
der greift nicht nur auf Informationen zu,
die direkt
von der Bahn kommen, sondern auf
die APIs aller Verkehrsverbünde
und Sachen, die auf der Wegstrecke liegen.
Und die sind, man glaubt es kaum,
nicht gesynkt.
Kann sein, dass die Bayerische Bahn
mehr weiß als die Hessische Bahn
und die, der MV
mehr als die offizielle Bahn-
API und sowas.
Hast du dir das Video angeguckt, wie das
X, XZ Backdoor, welches,
dazu gab es ja zig Videos.
So ein bisschen was haben wir uns ja damals schon angeguckt,
als es rausgekommen ist, aber da wusste keiner
so richtig Bescheid.
Äh, ja.
Ich glaube, das haben wir geguckt.
Jaja, das haben wir geguckt.
Oder was ähnliches von dem.
Ja.
So. Ich guck jetzt nochmal, Arch by the way,
ob es neue Package-Updates gibt.
Ich mein, wir haben zwar vorhin schon geupdatet,
aber das heißt ja nix.
Arch by the way.
Immer neue Updates.
Okay, Leute, heute Nachmittag machen wir weiter.
Oder Mittag, Mittag wahrscheinlich.
Ja, Mittag, Nachmittag machen wir weiter
mit unserem selbstgebauten Zigbee-Gerät.
Heute werde ich mal den Temperatursensor
dran löten.
Und mal gucken, wie wir den auslesen können.
Das Zigbee-Schicken hat ja das letzte Mal schon
mit
Tutorial-Copy-Pasten funktioniert.
Das machen wir heute vielleicht ein bisschen ordentlich.
Und dann schließen wir mal den Temperatursensor an.
Und gucken mal.
Ich setz mich dann da einfach
drauf auf den Temperatursensor.
Da gucken wir mal, ob der
misst. Ob das funktioniert.
Weiß nicht.
Dann sehen wir uns später wieder.
Ich kann's nicht versprechen,
aber ich habe
vor, heute Mittag
nochmal onzukommen.
Und jetzt geh ich erstmal was futtern.
Ach ja, Chatgear, was gibt's heute?
Ratet mal.
Nudel mit Lachs gab es letzte Woche.
Was gibt es heute?
Bolognese, korrekt.
Exzellent. Ich seh schon, ihr wisst Bescheid.
Ist ja auch nicht so kompliziert.
Es gibt zwei Sachen bei mir sonntags, ja.
Ach ja, bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.